sure
all right are we ready for the jury then
yes sir
all right
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen please be seated all right
your next witness yes good morning your
honor uh mr depp calls officer tyler
hadden and ladies and gentlemen of the
jury the first part of the testimony you
will hear is questioning uh by miss
heard's counsel and then we'll let you
know when mr depp's counsel takes over
the question all right thank you by
deposition thank you
please state your name and your business
address
tyler
adam
1546
west martin luther king junior boulevard
los angeles california
what is your occupation
i'm a police officer for the city of los
angeles
and how long have you been a police
officer with the city of los angeles
approximately five and a half years
did you serve in any law enforcement
capacity prior to coming to the lapd
no
when you said approximately five and a
half years do you recall
approximately you started employment
with the lapd
approximately november of 2015.
did you attend the police academy prior
to november 2015 or did you attend it
after you became employed by the lapd
you're on november of 2015.
in 2015 that november
that volume's a little loud
thank you
and how long were you with the academy
approximately six months
and when did you start
as a patrol officer with the lapd
uh six months after november
can you recall
your date when you started patrol i
don't recall the exact date no and that
would be may end of may of 2016.
right
and was the first
training officer that you worked with on
patrol melissa science
yes question when did you first have
body worn video assigned to you
i'm not sure of the exact date
approximately when
approximately three months into working
patrol
so maybe during the summer time
the summer of 2016.
correct
when you started working with
melissa science as your training officer
did officer science have body video
not at the time i worked with her how
much training did you have on domestic
violence while you were at the academy
i don't recall the exact amount of time
approximately how much
20 hours approximately
okay
so just to make sure that i understand
if you have a few disjointed questions
and answers so it was your understanding
as of
may 2016
that if you
answered a call for domestic violence
and there was evidence of a crime even
if the victim did not want to press
charges
that you had to take a report is that
correct
if there's evidence of a crime yes so
so
your best recollection today
is that you
had been on patrol as a probationary
officer somewhere between a week and
three weeks before answering the may 21
2016
domestic violence call at eastern
columbia building is that correct
right
do you recall any of the other incidents
that you reported to
that evening
of may 21st 2016.
at all any part of them
nope
so
this was new for you working with
officer science is that correct
right
and as the probationary officer
then
you would defer to officer science is
that fair
correct
and if you could just describe to me
what your understanding of officer
science role
was to you as your training officer in
may 2016
to
teach me and
guide me on how to become a
complete the duties of being a law
enforcement officer
officer hadden
under your understanding of the lapd
rules
in 2016.
if
a victim of domestic violence said that
the altercation was only verbal
would you
would that require you to write a report
no
okay
now i'm going to ask you to take a look
at the first page of what has been
marked as deposition exhibit number one
number faction number three my apology
um
and this is an incident recall
do you what is your understanding of
what this document
uh it's is what
is given to us on
our computer
and what do you mean is given to us on
our computer in our car
right so
what happens
so when we're assigned a radio call the
radio call comes to our computer and our
car
and this is what we see on our screen
but
in a different format
now
how was this particular call
characterized
by the dispatch at least initially
initially it was dispatched as a
domestic radio phone
okay
and what is
domestic radio call mean to you
that there's
some type of whether it's disagreement
all the way up to
a
violent crime that's occurred between
two people are in some type of
relationship or have some children in
common
so officer had
this comes out into the system
and it's accessible by all of the
lapd black and whites that are on patrol
that night correct
yes whoever is logged in and working
that night i could look up any divisions
radio calls if i wanted to
and then it has next it has a ds
and then er after stat what does that
mean ds means dispatched
er means we're in route
so
at 8 46
and 37 seconds pm
your vehicle was on route to 849 south
broadway correct
correct
you recall how far away you were
i do not recall
and then it says primary unit pd1a1-w3
what is that
that's my call assignment so the pd is
police department i want me one is my
car assignment w3 means i work watch
three
okay
then we have at 20
57 which is 8 57 p.m
that is a s what does that mean
at scene
like we're there
right so so you arrived at the scene at
8 57 pm correct
right
what did you do then
um we
walked to the location
do you recall
[Music]
anything that you did before you went up
to the
penthouse uh we walked in and
met with security who showed us where
the elevator was
did you do anything else
[Music]
um but your best recollection is that
you went in you talked to security and
then you
went on an elevator is that right
yes
do you recall what time you arrived at
the
apartment the penthouse no i don't know
all right then your next entry here is
21 22.
so that would be 9 22 p.m and 57 seconds
yeah
net with victim
deck lock verified has been last
location
victim advised verbal do you see that
that's what we write
when we put the comments of the call of
what happened in the radio call that's
what we wrote
so do you recall whether that was you
that wrote that or officer science
um i don't recall the road all right
and and so you were back in your vehicle
by 9 22 is that correct
approximately yeah
well if you wrote this at 9 22
would it be fair to say you were back in
your vehicle writing this yes
okay
um
now did you take a report
uh we issued a business card
i asked did you take a report no why not
because
the
victim didn't request report and during
our investigation didn't reveal that we
need to take a report
so
who decided to use the words victim
advised verbal
dispute
the
whoever created the comments of the call
used the word victim
whoever gave the comments of the call
gave use the word victim
so i don't know who that was
and i'm even more specifically
asking who chose the language advised
verbal dispute
is either my partner or i i don't recall
who
now what is the significance of writing
down verbal dispute
we're writing what happened what we
believe has happened and what we
our investigation revealed
but
you were not
present at any time
when
ms heard discussed
whether there was any type of verbal
argument is that correct was i there yes
was i speaking to her no
was there any discussion
of verbal argument in your presence
in when you were up in the the penthouse
investigating
not that i refuse
you did not hear ms heard say that it
was only a verbal dispute correct
i did not
now
i asked you a little earlier if it's a
verbal dispute whether that triggers
having to write a report
and you indicated that it is not
am i accurately characterizing that
right
okay
now here in addition to the
victim-advised verbal dispute
says and refused
to give any further information
you see that
yes
question okay so if the victim does not
want to press charges and and advises
that it's a verbal dispute then that
would not trigger you writing a report
is that your understanding of lapd
all season procedures on domestic
violence at that time correct there are
other circumstances that were also
within this incident as well
what do you mean by that
during our investigation we had other
reasons to believe that this was true
i'm sorry during your investigation you
had other reasons to believe what was
true
that it was a verbal dispute
and what
did you
have during your investigation that
created in your mind evidence that it
was only a verbal dispute
after discussing the investigation with
my partner at the city
the
uh misheard
uh refused any medical treatment and had
no visible injuries there was no sign of
struggle
and
the victim or correction the witness
that was there that i spoke with was
uncooperative as well
anything else
at this time it's all
okay now
you recall
seeing that ms heard was in tears and
was crying and red-faced would you agree
correct from a distance
well
from a distance miss heard was in tears
crying and had a red face correct
correct why did you issue a business
it's part of our
policy we're supposed to issue a
business card and
it shows that we were there and
completed an investigation
and
if
she would like us to come back we
offered that assistance that we can come
back at another time if she feels like
she just come back
did you take any notes at all
no to what
no during the time that you were
investigating this call
no
did you take any notes after you got
back down to your car about the call
no
did you take any pictures
no
did you record anything
no
would it be fair to say that on 5 21
2016 at 9 22 pm
you and your training officer
science
considered this incident closed i said
yes that is correct at that time
we
pressed enter and the call went off my
screen meaning it was completed
did you
ever have anything come up on your
screen again relating to this incident
that evening
not that i recall all right at the time
that you closed out this incident on
your screen at 9 22 on 5 21
2016
did you know that this call involved
johnny depp
no
did you
at the time that you closed this out on
your screen
were you did you recognize amber heard
no i had no idea who she was
and is it fair to say
that you
considered these people to be
quote just citizens end of quote
that's correct
do you have any communications
at all with officer gatlin or his his
patrol partner
the night
of
may 21st 2016. no not that i recall
so the next thing we're going to go to
is the cad summary which is at page 12
of exhibit number
three
and this is a cad summary report and it
also has the name dfar report at the top
and it's for 521 2016.
and says specifically
officers hadden and officer
signs
do you see that yes typically
when you would arrive for your shift
was there a period of time that you
would do things maybe at the uh at the
precinct or whatever before you get into
your vehicle and log on and go forward
yes
what typically would you do back in 2016
i would
change
put on my uniform
and then i would have a roll call
we'd be giving our assignments
and then we would stand in line and
check out our equipment
and check out our car
and then we have to go
put our equipment in the car
and then wash the car
vacuum the car
gas the car
and then
go and find out if there's any radio
calls pending
okay and so
how long would it typically take for you
to do all those things from putting your
uniform on through the time you start
checking for radio calls
um
i'm not sure approximately an hour
all right how many people
how many police officers patrol officers
were part of that
that roll call
i don't know the exact number i would
say
approximately 30.
and when you said you had to stand in
line to check out your equipment was it
all 30 of those patrol officers that
would get in line and check out their
equipment yes and supervisors
okay
um and
what equipment were you checking out
that night
uh
a shotgun a less lethal shotgun
mics for our cameras inside the car
pouches for our mics
batteries for our radios
keys for the cars
hazer
um
i think that's about it right now
do you have a recollection of there
being cameras inside your car back on
may 21 2016
yes i believe so now
when
you arrived at the penthouse
you saw that there was a female
holding and embracing
ms heard correct
i believe it was uh when i was leaving
the location when we were getting ready
to leave
okay
now
you believed that ms heard was
uncooperative
because she was being emotional
crying
was refusing
uh
that she
was hurt and she didn't know initially
whether she wanted to file a report or
not and then she didn't want to file a
report correct
right
now
you said that officer science told you
later that ms heard called the number on
the business card
do you recall when officer science told
you that ms heard called the number on
the card no i don't recall
do you recall approximately how much
time you spent
at the penthouse speaking with either
the mail or with ms heard or looking at
the premises
uh don't recall right now
you
recall roughly whether it was 15 minutes
a half hour hour
i don't i don't
recall i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as
deposition exhibit number 17. i'll just
scroll down so you can see that hold on
do you recognize the person in this
photo
i believe that's this hurt
all right is this the same person you
saw on the night of may 21 2016
when you arrived sometime after 904 pm
and do you recall seeing the red marks
that are reflected on
this exhibit number 17 on ms third no i
was never this close to uh be able to
examine her face
you were never never close enough to
miss her to be able to examine her face
is that what you said right
okay
um
if you had seen
these this mark close enough to be able
to see it
would you have believed you had an
obligation to prepare a report
no because i don't know what this is
from
right
would you agree it's a red mark on her
face
from what i saw was
red from her crying there was no red
marks from
any other thing it was consistent with
her crying
does this look like a red mark that's
from crying officer hadn't um
would
in reviewing this picture
does it appear that there's an injury
on
ms heard's face into this picture no
you would say that doesn't evidence an
injury
no
why not
because i don't see an injury
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as deposition exhibit number 18.
and uh
do you recognize this carpeting
no
officer
what do you see in this picture i see
stripes
with
some type of stains on uh
to be a possible flooring
okay
do you have a recollection of seeing
stains on the flooring
um
outside of ms heard's
penthouse that night
of may 21st 2016.
at this point not gonna recall
and when you say at this point now that
you can recall what do you mean by that
it's five years ago i don't remember
officer hadn't i'm going to show you
what is in mark just had in exhibit
number 19
do you recognize the business card
yes
and tell me what you can recall of that
um well that's my handwriting and those
are our lapd business cards
the next thing on there is refuse report
you see that yes okay
was it your understanding that ms heard
did not want to press charges
uh she spoke with my partner and that's
what my partner advised me
okay were you ever in the room when ms
heard
either quote refused report or refused
to press charges
i believe we offered her one final
chance before we gave her the business
card if she needed medical treatment or
a report
and she declined at that time and that's
when we issued this
and what did you mean by report
um an official
investigative report
is that the victim's choice to write
whether you write an official
investigative report
yeah uh a citizen can read ask for a
report for anything essentially with
lapd
but
do you have
an obligation as an lapd patrol officer
to write a report if you see injuries or
property
if there's evidence of a crime yes
and when you say if there's evidence of
a crime would injuries and property
damage constitute evidence of a crime
if there's evidence of a crime again
okay
is there something different about what
you're saying than what i'm asking
well i'm trying to understand when i say
if you see evidence of injuries and
property damage is that evidence of a
crime in your mind
yes if the person didn't commit do it
themselves i mean i i can damage my own
property it's not a crime
okay
did you have any reason to believe that
amber heard
created any injuries to herself or to
the property at the time you were there
on
may 21 2016. no it's not repulsing any
damaged property or her obtaining any
injuries or having invisible injuries
that i saw
now it says advise can paul at later
time
if changes mind
what if any discussion did you have with
officer signs about what that meant
well that goes with what i said earlier
was
a citizen can make a report about
anything
at any time it's called investigative
report or just an incident report
so if she wanted a report then she would
call us back and we'll take a report
but at that point you have already
written into your system that the victim
advised verbal dispute only correct
correct
and you did not write a report or take
pictures or
uh create any kind of
record did you of anything that
transpired there
just the business part
i'm gonna ask you
officer had to take a look at what has
been marked as deposition exhibit number
24.
do you recognize the person in this
picture
this hurt
well do you recognize her as miss hurt
um
no no i had no idea who she was do you
recognize the person in this picture on
hadden exhibit number 24
as the person
who was the
the
subject of
your and officer signs
reporting to
the eastern columbia building that
evening
correct
all right so let's go to uh exhibit
number 24 um
and do you
what do you see in this picture with
respect to whether there is any injury
depicted on ms hurt i see a uh female
white fair skin with uh
some tree
started with a white
pink cheek
and pink eyes
all right
do you
recognize that as a potential injury on
her face
knowing what our investigation revealed
no it's that pink's consistent with
brian
what do you mean by what your
investigation revealed
that it was a
verbal dispute
and she refused that she had any injury
and just so we're clear again
you were never
in the presence of miss heard when she
at any time said it was only a verbal
dispute right
right how
would you as a police officer
investigating
if you saw this
what's depicted in this picture
would you believe that you need to
investigate further uh yeah i would need
additional information
uh just because i see a female with
pink cheeks and pink eyes doesn't mean
that
something happened
they should be sad and crying that their
dog died
did you
engage in any further investigation no
the only investigation i did was part of
speaking my partner and then
uh speaking with the witness
with the witness the next door neighbor
and what did you discuss with the
witness the next door neighbor
i tried to obtain information of what
occurred
what did you ask
uh who what when where why
and what did he say
uh i don't remember his exact words but
he wasn't
very coming with uh the information
i have very vague vague information as
far as
what he was telling me
what do you specifically call
the witness telling you
i don't recall
you don't recall at all i don't recall
specific words or sentences
do you recall the witness
taking you around and showing you
property damage in the penthouse
no i recall my part and i doing a
protective sweep
and that's it
you don't recall
josh drew being with you
and taking you through
i don't recall i don't recall someone
else was with us or not
do you recall one way or the other
i
i don't recall
all right now you have a recollection of
you and and officer science
going through the entire penthouse is
that correct we did a protective sweep
of
the location that she was at
tell me what you mean by protective
suite we walk through
the general housing area that she is at
to make sure that
there's no one else in it that shouldn't
be there or there's
no
you know no no one hurt
do you recall how many rooms you went
through no no i don't
know i'm gonna ask you if the officer
had to take a look at number 25 you
recognize this as miss heard
yes
right and do you
see any injuries depicted on this
picture
no
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as exhibit number 26. do you
recognize this as miss heard yes
okay do you see any injuries
in this picture
no
i'm going to ask you the same question
uh exhibit number 27 do you recognize
this as miss heard yes
and do you see any injuries
in this picture on this right no
i'm getting asked the same questions
officer hadden
uh
i'm going to ask you to look at had an
exhibit number 28 do you recognize this
as misheard
yes
and do you see any injuries depicted on
ms heard's face in this picture no
i'll show you exhibit number 29 do you
recognize this as miss word yes
do you see any injuries on this heard in
this picture
no
now you indicated that you and officer
signs uh
went through the
apartment correct
correct we did a protective sweep
detective suite and in doing the
protective sweep you did go in the room
correct
uh well i mean i don't know exactly
where we went but we walked around
what she claimed was her
living quarter
would you agree that if ms heard
displayed injuries at the time that you
reported to her residents after the
domestic violence call that you would
have had an obligation to prepare a
report
if there was uh injuries or a complaint
of pain yes
i'm sorry injuries are what complain
opinion
would you agree that
uh if ms heard displayed injuries that
you perceive to be injuries at the time
you reported to ms herd's residence
after the domestic violence call on may
21st 2016 you had an obligation to to
prepare a report
if i perceive them to be injuries then
yes
would you agree that if there was
property damage present
at the time you reported to ms heard's
residence after the domestic violence
calls you had an obligation to prepare a
report
no because if she's living there that's
her property
and she's being uncooperative and
doesn't say that
someone else did it
or
anyone else did it then
i have no other information to go off of
she could have broken it herself
sir
did you
provide any
pamphlets to ms hearn new or officer
signs relating to domestic violence
i personally did not
do you know whether officer science did
i don't know
and ladies and gentlemen at this point
counsel for mr depp takes over the
question
did you see ms hurt's face on the
evening of may 21 2016. yes
on how many occasions did you see her
face
i believe too
and the first time
you saw
her face uh how close to her were you
uh i don't recall exactly i think it was
approximately 10 feet
did you perceive any uh did you have any
um
problems with your eyesight at that time
did you have 20 20 vision as of may 21
2016
uh no i wear contacts though so i can't
see perfectly fine were you wearing your
contacts that evening
yes did you have any trouble uh seeing
the contours of her face the first time
you saw her that evening
did you perceive any signs of injury on
her face or anywhere else on her body
that was visible to you no
for how long a period did you
view her face the first time you saw her
that night
a few seconds not very long
and
how much later was the second time you
saw him misheard right before we left
and
how close
to her were you when you observed her
face
approximately 10 feet
did you have a clear view of her face
yes
did you still have your contacts in at
the time
yes
was there sufficient light that enabled
you to actually see her face i believe
so i
i believe it was uh the light was a
little dimmer but it was still lit
did you perceive any
signs of injury to her face on that
second occasion no
did you see
any swelling of any kind on her face
either do it during the first
time you saw her or the second time you
saw her that night no
did you see any marks on her face either
the first time you observed her that
night or the second time you observed
her just the redness for which was
consistent with her
crying did you did you see
any time that night any indication of
any bruising on her face
no
did you see at any time that evening any
any indication
or any sign whatsoever of any injury to
her face
no
and going to
your
was it the security what was the term
you used the security sweep is that
correct
the protective suite protective sweep
during your protective sweep
was your access bar to any part of the
pet house my access what sorry
uh did you have
free access uh to to the penthouse
the the witness that was there he kind
of i believe he guided us kind of
through
the place well i don't know
you know wherever he guided us through
did you see any broken glass anywhere in
the penthouse where you did the
protective sweep
not that i remember
were you looking for any signs of a
disturbance
yes
why were you looking for signs of a
possible disturbance
um signs of
any evidence that a crime has occurred
is that part of is that standard
procedure a police procedure
yes and why
do you look for potential signs of
vandalism or disturbance to property in
the course of a domestic violence
violence allegation or possibility
um just because that tends to happen
when uh
uh
some type of domestic
altercation occurs between two people
did you see any sign of any kind of
property damage or vandalism that
evening
not that i recall
did you see any signs of spilled wine on
the floor
not that i recall
if they were visible or uh completely
pain do you recall
some questioning from ms heard's counsel
ms breth
about
a man who led you through the penthouses
on the evening of may 21 2016. yes
did you um
describe him as uncooperative
let me ask another question was he
cooperative
with your inquiries that evening no
what do you mean by that
i attempted to gather information of
who the husband was
and what occurred
and um where he possibly went
um so we could interview kind of all the
different parties
and uh
he he wouldn't wouldn't give me a name
of who the husband was
and
how long did you interact with that
person who who in fact is josh drew
uh
i'd say approximately five to ten
minutes
did he report to you in words or
substance
that any domestic violence had occurred
i don't recall any exact verbiage he
said
did he report to you in words or
substance
any vandalism
no not that i recall
on the evening that uh you and your
partner got a call uh to the penthouse
on may 21 2016
were you and your partner in a
particular hurry to close out of this
incident no
you were you willing to to stay as long
as was necessary to to resolve the
matter
yes
would you generally take notes for a
verbal dispute only when when we
uh
disciple the call we get rid of the call
we leave our comments of what occurred
and what we did in that call would you
generally write a report
for a verbal dispute only
no unless it's uh
at the request of one of the parties
when you were typing in your computer to
add text to a call
is it common to refer to the focus
individual in the call as a victim
whether she whether a crime has been
committed or not yes because that's how
the
fall was broadcasted and created
ladies and gentlemen at this point
counsel for
miss heard
completes the questioning
now there was another woman that was
present
as well correct that name
um
i believe so yes
do you remember testifying earlier that
at the end she was holding and embracing
miss heard
yeah i believe she's on sitting on the
couch with her until we left
did you interview that woman
no she was with uh
uh misheard when uh my partner was
speaking with her i believe
she i never spoke to her
because did you ever attempt to
interview that woman that was on the
couch who was embracing this building no
because i was speaking with the
gentleman outside
do you know whether officer science ever
attempted to interview that woman who
was sitting on the couch
i'm unaware
okay
now let's go back to
the description that you gave and you
responded again to it with mr
chu
that
she had she was crying
and had a red face and you said the
redness was consistent with crying do
you recall that
yes
okay why was she crying i don't know
that's a great question i don't know why
she was crying
did you ask her
i personally did not because my partner
interviewed her
then when you downloaded with your
partner later did you ask for officer
science why amber heard was crying
no my partner never advised me she spoke
with her and
while i was speaking with the gentleman
do you recall that you testified that
there was another woman who was
embracing this herd on the sofa at the
end of your visit
yes
do you
recall asking why she was bracing and
holding ms heard why
did you not ask either the other woman
or ms heard why the woman was embracing
and holding this herd
well i did not is because we were
trained in the academy to separate the
parties and to try and attempt to build
a rapport with the individual we're
speaking with
therefore it was two females and my
partner was female so therefore my
partner spoke with the females
would it be fair to say you deferred to
officer signs to conduct any type of
investigation with both ms heard and the
other woman who was embracing her
i know my partner spoke with
miss heard i am unaware i cannot testify
if she spoke with the other
female
when you said you learned at the academy
to divide up the parties was it your
understanding that parties meant the
victim and the suspect
all parties
do you know whether anyone made an
attempt to divide up the woman from ms
heard the woman that was embracing her
i'm unaware
okay now
the redness that you said was on miss
herb's face
uh when she was
crying and emotional
could it also have been consistent with
injury i do not think so i had perceived
it as redness from crying
did you consider
whether the redness on the face
might be from something in addition to
crying
no i did not
and you had never met ms heard before
correct
never never
and would it be fair to say that you
don't know what ms heard
what her characteristics are for
swelling bruising
redness correct
correct
i'm going to ask you officer hadden to
look at what has been marked as uh had
an exhibit number eight and it's from
the office of the chief of police
and it's
dated november 24 2014
and the subject is domestic violence
supplemental report form
15.40.02 revised do you see that
i do
this was provided to us by the lapd in
response to our document requests
did you have an understanding
uh that there was a domestic violence
supplemental report form that was in
place as of now as of may 21 2016.
yes
i'm going to show you what is exhibit
number nine
and
this is called domestic violence
supplemental report
and it is something is it your
understanding that the police officer
fills this out
yes and we fill that up
okay
do you recall whether you had filled out
this supplemental report
at any time prior to may twenty first
two thousand sixteen
i don't know
now if we look at the first column on
the domestic violence supplemental
report
it has a column that says victim
and then there are a number of
descriptive words underneath with boxes
do you see that i do
all right now the first one is shaking
what if any observations did you make of
ms heard shaking
i don't know
all right what if any uh observations
did you make about misheard being
unresponsive
the little time i
dealt with her
uh yeah she was unresponsive crying
i'm sorry i didn't catch the first part
she was unresponsive and crying did you
say
yes
okay
and i guess you've answered the third
one here that she was crying correct
yes
all right and what if any observations
did you make whether amber heard was
scared
i didn't
you didn't what i did not observe
i'm sorry
are you finished with that answer it
sounded like it was a half i just want
to make sure you yeah i did not observe
her being
fearful okay but ms heard did not want
to
file a report correct
correct
you did not want to
press charges correct
right
and she did not want to tell you the
name of her husband correct no because
they're talking
well do you recall
testifying earlier
that ms heard was uncooperative
yes she was uncooperative with my
partner
all right and do you recall testifying
that miss heard was uncooperative
because she was emotional she was crying
she wasn't sure whether she wanted to
file a report or not and she was not
then she said she did not want to
yes that's
what she had spoke with my partner about
do you know why
miss heard did not want to file a report
i did not want to press charges no i did
not
officer hadn't i'm going to show you
what has been marked as deposition
exhibit number 10. and
i'm going to have you looked at it it
starts out with field notebook divider
domestic violence laws lapd form 18.3
0.02
and it has the date this is the
date of january 31 2010 at the bottom
with the uh
with the footnote i'm going to just
direct your attention here to case
preparation and this is relating to
domestic violence laws
case preparation says note the
complainant's emotional and physical
condition you see that
yes
and then ensure all evidence is gathered
and preserved
bg bloody closing clothing damaged bones
damaged property
you see that
yes
okay did you or officer
signs
provide any kind of notes relating to ms
heard's emotional and physical condition
on may 21 2016.
no
did you or officer science ensure all
the evidence was gathered and preserved
including a damaged property i said no
and all these things would have been
documented if there was a report
right let's go to the next bullet points
says ensure photographs are taken of
injuries
or
lack of injury
to complainant
and accused
both the day of and
after
did you take any photographs to show a
lack of injury
no
did you take any photos to show a lack
of damage
no
all right
and then this next one is ensure
photographs are taken of the scene and
damaged property etc
so i've already asked you that one so
let's go to the next one canvas location
and interview all witnesses
including children neighbors law
enforcement
did you do that in this instance
yes
where did you interview
i spoke with the gentleman all right
anyone else
no that's it
now there were two
females present in addition to ms hurd
were there nine
uh yes uh
including her i believe there's two you
don't recall the third woman there no i
don't recall a third one being there
all right did you ask if there was
anybody else that was present who had
witnessed any aspect of
this
um i don't recall exactly but all right
let's go to
exhibit number 11.
so what did you determine this call was
after your investigation
a dispute
a verbal dispute
it's not against the law to argue i
argue in my life
so you decided that there was only a
verbal dispute therefore it didn't
constitute domestic violence from the
information or lack of information i was
able to receive from the witness and the
information my partner gathered yes is
it your understanding that
a police officer
can be brought up on charges of
misconduct
if they engage in
neglect of duty
uh yes
right is it also your understanding that
a police officer can be brought
up on misconduct charges at the lapd
if they violate department policies
rules or procedures
yes
and is it your understanding that a
police officer can be brought up on
charges of misconduct if they engage in
conduct which may tend to reflect
unfavorably upon the employee or the
department
yes
all right
thank you your next witnesses by
deposition also i assume you need a few
minutes to switch that out are you ready
to
we're ready
oh i think that's that's right okay well
we go ahead and it's early but let's go
ahead and take a morning recess for 15
minutes so we can take care of that and
get it set up with the next deposition
okay so don't talk to anybody don't do
the outside research all right
um
okay who's the next which deposition is
next officer william gatlin your honor
officer gatlins
okay and how long is this deposition
i believe it's around 35 minutes your
honor okay so we'll be able to start the
next one right now we should be able to
go ahead and get the exhibits for the
next one after that as well and i'll
come back at 11 20 and we can do both of
them okay thank you all right thank you
which evidence do we have
yeah
all right are we ready for the jury then
yes okay yes your honor
so
you
all right thank you for your next
witness
okay
officer gatlin could you spell the last
name for me in the court quarter
and business address for the record
william gatlin
uh business address 251 east 6th street
in los angeles california
uh
90014
how long have you been an officer with
the lapd
uh eight years
and what is your rank
uh police officer two
now your partner on may 21 2016 was
officer dean was that correct yes
you were wearing your body cam
on 21 2016 yes
when were you first assigned body
cameras
um
sometime in 2015
i think
uh you know i don't remember gatlin i'm
going to show you what has been marked
as
defendant's exhibit number six
um
and i'm going to go ahead and go down to
the second page
and this is the incident recall
for
the two for you and
officer deaner
for
may 21 2016
in connection with the call at the
eastern columbia building 849 south
broadway
now officer deaner indicated that he
believed that he was driving that night
is that your recollection as well
uh yes when officer deaner is driving
what does that mean you're doing
uh it means i handle
the computer
based on the incident recall when did
you arrive at the scene u.n officer
demon we arrived at scene it looks like
at 22 24.
and that is
10 24
correct so when you arrived do you
recall whether there were any other
police
officers that were on the scene
i do not believe there was
do you recall whether there was any
press on the scene
i do not believe there was
do you recall whether there was any type
of public gathering of all
no
was it relatively quiet
uh from my recollection yes
uh did you see very many people in the
lobby when you came through
not that i remember
okay
um
and then tell me what you recall
of this incident once you got there and
you were shown to the elevator
i remember we went up the elevator um
exited the elevator
walked down the hallway until we found
the unit number
knocked on the door and mail answered
the door
and uh
at that point
i mean at that point i i really didn't
know
whether this guy is potentially the
suspect if this guy is involved in the
altercation or who this guy was
so we kind of talked to him for a second
and he advised us that the police had
already been there he had a business
card from them
and we told him that we
still needed to step inside to check on
the subject or potential victim just to
make sure that
she's okay and that this is uh indeed
related to the previous incident and not
a new incident where the suspect had
potentially
returned and caused there's another new
issue at hand
so do you recall that you already knew
that this had this place had that
another officer had had uh answered the
caller other officers had answered the
call before you got there yes i already
knew there was a previous caller and how
did you know that
um
just kind of keeping track when you're
on the computer you kind of are able to
keep track of the calls throughout the
night and
where they're at and what's going on
and did you know that officer science
and and hadn't had been the ones who had
answered the call earlier
um
i i believe so
okay
um
did you speak with officer science or
officer hadden before you went to
the eastern columbia w
no
i'm going to take you down to
the same exhibit
the page that's uh
bait stamp numbered lapd 11
and i'm going to ask you this is a
t-o-m-s-g data line do you recognize
this document
i've never seen this before i've never
seen one of these documents before
all right do you have a recollection
of receiving an administrative message
at 22 22 30 which would be 10 22 30. uh
saying
uh incident
4756 is the same incident as yours 1a1
handled earlier
doubt she called back probably just
delayed response
uh i did not recall i do not recall
getting that message right below it
at 22 23 22 which is 10 23 and change
it shows
that
your unit responded with rob in other
words roger
to that message do you see that yes
would that have been you that did that
or would that have been officer deena
uh probably me
okay and is that because you weren't
driving an officer dean or was yes
okay so does this refresh your
of what had been communicated to you and
why you knew that someone had already
answered this call earlier
uh
yes
are you familiar with the term cycle of
violence
yes
well typically do you make arrests on
domestic abuse
calls um
you know sometimes we do and sometimes
the other party is no longer at scene
and we would just take a report
okay are there times where they just
refused to cooperate and you just left
um
yeah but yeah there are terms like that
we're going to say but what i guess like
the totality of the circumstance based
on
just because someone's uncooperative
doesn't automatically mean that we'll
just leave you know if we're you know
observe some kind of injuries or if
there's a third-party witness that's
cooperative that could lean in where
even if the victim's uncooperative that
would still take some sort of action now
i'm going to ask you to turn to
number page 13 here
and this is the
cad summary report what if any uh
involvement did you have in this
um so
i would be the one that kind of closes
out the incidents on the computer
so the
writings over to the right of the screen
would be
the how i would what i would type into
the computer to close out the call
and so you would have typed in related
to previous incident verbal argument
only checked residence yes
who told you that it was a verbal
argument only
uh based on
the knowledge i had of the previous call
i'm able to see
[Music]
potentially how they closed out the call
and i could have seen it from there
so you could have gotten this from a1a
1a1 yeah their report officer science
and officer hadn't and then just
repeated it here
uh yes
okay do you have any recollection of
anyone
in the apartment
up in penthouse 3
saying that there had been a verbal
argument only
um not to my recollection
let me just jump back to the events of
may 21 for a moment were you aware that
that was the apartment of johnny depp
and amber
no
when did you first become aware of that
um i don't remember
okay we're talking months days hours it
was a couple days
and do you remember how you learned of
it
no i don't
and did you know who johnny depp was at
that time uh yeah
and were you a fan of johnny depp's as
of may 21 2016.
um
i guess i liked a couple of his movies
i'm not like rushing out to go see him
or anything i don't know
are you a fan of johnny depp's today
i can remember the last movie i saw his
did you know who amber heard was as of
may 21 2016
uh i was aware that there was an actress
by the name of amber heard but i'm not
was not totally familiar with her or any
of her
any of her work
when you saw
the name amber heard
on the uh
incident he
recalls
did it register with you that she was an
actress
no
did you recognize amber heard when you
came to the apartment on may 21 2016. no
how close did you come to amber heard
while you were in the apartment
um
about to say probably between 10 and 15
feet
and what was the lighting like where
amber horde was sitting
it's pretty uh dim
did you ask to see amber heard's face in
the light
no
did you ask and referred whether she had
any injuries
no
did you interview any of the persons
present about what had taken place
earlier that night
no
why not
uh because i was aware that there's a
previous call regarding the incident and
the mail that answered the door
uh kind of made it clear to us that this
is still
left over from that same incident and a
new incident had not occurred
so
i didn't feel the need to at that time
did you go through and search the entire
apartment including bedrooms offices and
other areas no
again why not
uh it's the same as i explained earlier
and they were all adamant that
her husband was no longer at scene
did you go into any of the other
adjoining apartments no
you asked where the husband was why did
you ask for the husband
uh because in the comments of the call
it stated the uh
husband and wife were arguing
and it was also a domestic violence
yeah it's domestic violence call and it
wouldn't be uncommon for
you know the mail to answer the door to
tell us that he's not the husband and
later it turns out that he is so you
know we kind of have to talk to
the other party involved to make sure
that that's not
the mail that's involved in the argument
did any of the four people that were in
the apartment
identify
johnny depp as that male 1
no
was there any effort by any of the
people in that apartment to get you to
press charges or investigate further
no
would you say that people were reluctant
to even have you come into the apartment
it felt that way
and what how what occurred that made it
feel like that to you that they didn't
want to be they didn't want you in the
apartment um just the uh
the way that the male was acting they
answered the door he kind of just said
oh let me just go grab the business card
from the previous call
and then even so when we had went inside
uh it didn't seem like anybody was
particularly eager to talk to us
uh i'm going to ask you to take a look
at exhibit one defendant's exhibit one
[Music]
and this is uh the daily mail
mail online july 3rd 2020 and i'm going
to go down to
the 10th page
what if any evidence
did you
observe when you went to the penthouse
on may 21 2016 that amber heard and her
friends
were attempting to concoct an abuse hoax
to set up johnny depp to be accused of
domestic violence
none that i can recall
what if any evidence did you see
amber and her friends spilling wine and
roughing the place up none
and what if any evidence did you see
that amber and her friends
were
had concocted and gotten their story
straight and were relaying them to you
when you arrived
none
did amber or her friends at any time
while you were at the apartment on may
21 2016
claim
that johnny depp had committed domestic
violence of amber not to me they didn't
did you see them do that to officer
deaner
no
what if any
efforts did amber heard
make to come over and to show you any
evidence of injuries
[Music]
and what if any effort did amber heard
or her friends make to try to show you
any type of property damage
none
and what if any evidence do you have
that amber or her friends
may place a second call to 9-1-1 i don't
have any evidence that it was one of her
friends i just know that there's a
second call place
well actually if i can recall i think
it said that uh her friend was on the
phone with her and heard her arguing
with her husband
who said that i believe that's what the
incident recall said
did you ever provide a sworn deposition
uh saying that you sign her evidence of
a crime at the penthouse before today
no
are you aware of whether officer deaner
provided a sworn deposition saying he
saw no evidence he has not
uh now this
uh
call came in 2030 which is approximately
8 30
uh regular
p.m right yes
okay
um and then a little bit further down
just seven minutes later
comes a duplicate call
that appears to come from the new york
police department
roughly seven minutes of each other
correct yes
did you see that when you were looking
back at trying to look at the history
uh i believe i saw all of this did you
see in any of the incident recalls or
any of the documentation that you
reviewed
that
there the officers officer science
manhattan reported to the scene
left the scene closed out and then
another call was made to come to 849
south broadway
um
yes
what did you see
the second call created was the one that
we had received
and it says
this is 2209 which would be 1009 right
roughly yes
it says teletype from nypd i can't
female stated she was on the phone with
her friend she began screaming at her
husband
subject amber heard husband johnny heard
male 53 years old 511 nfd nfl do you see
that yes
okay
but that's new york police department
and back here
it says new york police department
correct correct
okay
but
after you communicated
down here
on the administrative
text messages and i'm now on lapd 11.
this is 2222
you now know it's the same incident as
yours and 1a1 handled earlier
doubt she called back probably just
delayed response correct yeah this is
just a message from another unit so i
mean
uh just because they're telling they're
basically just sending a message that
it's related
you know it it doesn't mean that
it's exactly the same call by the time
you showed up at the door penthouse 3
at the eastern columbia building
you already knew
that officer science had handled this
call and you were just double checking
to make sure that the perpetrator wasn't
there and that everybody was okay
correct i was aware that officer science
had handled a call at that location
earlier
but it doesn't mean that i
have to that i treat it as if it's
handled already we still have to
get there and speak to them and make
that determination
that it's not a completely new incident
okay
and you did that right yes
and you put in the system
for this call
21 20 20 46 to 2122
met with vic check location verified
husband left location victim advised
verbal dispute and refused to give any
further information actually that was
handling signs right that wasn't me i
didn't put that in
then what you put in that was why i
couldn't find it you put in
22-17 and i'm sure you weren't there
until 301 but we talked about some dates
about that you put in related to
previous incident verbal argument only
check resonance correct yes
okay
and
your putting verbal argument only was
based on what you could review with
science manhattan correct
uh yes
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as defendant's exhibit number two
uh and it's a
picture it's a portion of a video clip
from the ecb building
and it has 5 21 2016 and the time is 22
28 14.
uh do you recognize the person in this
picture yes and who who is in this
picture officer deaner i'm going to ask
you to take a look at defendant's
exhibit number three
and that's
reflecting a video clip again
and it's david 5 21 2016 and says 22 28
15. um do you recognize the person in
this yeah that's me and officer diner
i'm going to uh show you now the video
cam footage i've got the two
from yours and from officer
dinner so i'm going to go through and
show those to you
um
coffee's hot
burning up
word round penthouse
we advise 3. stepping on on to the
penthouse club
[Music]
is
[Music]
hello
officers how are you doing doing all
right
yeah we got another call i don't know if
it's related to the same call from
earlier or if somebody called again
probably
whoever it is you know step out you just
gotta check out and make sure they're
all good i'll go get the business card
from the cops
yeah i don't know just because we got
another call and we came again we still
got to make sure
please back up
[Music]
[Music]
or whoever called but we just got
another notification
so
we just knew they'd come in to make sure
that everybody's okay
they're all good nobody else is in here
no
the other officer came by and checked
department and the other apartment as
well
it must have been like a double call
okay who's amber
johnny
is definitely not here
probably like two hours ago
okay yeah all right cool
everything's all good then
now let's get it all right thank
you guys need anything else just call us
back
good night
so this one is that is defendant's
exhibit number four
coffee's hot
burning up
word round penthouse three
before we go further can you to uh show
you now the you're putting virgin says
22 28
um do you recognize the person in this
yeah that's me and officer deaner
i'm going to uh show you now the video
cam footage i've got the two
from yours and from officer
deaner so i'm going to go through and
show those to you
so this one is defendant's exhibit
number four
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
before we go further can you tell
whether this one is your video cam
footage or it is officer damage
uh this appears to be officer deaners
and so that's you over here yes
can you tell whether it's you or officer
dana that's saying officer signs
um i cannot tell okay how did you know
that it was officer signs who'd been
there uh because i was aware which unit
had responded to the call there and i
knew the shoes working that unit
was related to the same call from
earlier or if somebody called again
probably we just see the check
someone in new york or something yeah
she could probably call it twice okay
you just talk to your wife and make sure
it's not mine
oh okay
different conversations
yeah well whoever it is
they're all good i'll
[Music]
now would you say and this is i'll
represent this as josh drew and he's
already provided testimony would you say
that josh drew
was discouraging you from even coming
into the apartment
or seeing amber heard
yes
i don't know if she called twice or
whoever called but we just got another
notification
so
we just need to come in and make sure
that everybody's okay
yeah and they're all good nobody else is
in here no
the other officer came by
all right officer gatlin can you tell
which one of these people is doing the
talking of these three girls
women uh
i can't tell for sure but it appears to
me it's the
girl in the middle
that's
the one that's leaning forward with the
white shirt
do you know which one of these is amber
herb
um from this view i can't tell
all right do you know what color care
the person that's the most forward
that's in the middle has
uh i can't tell from this
okay can you tell what color hair the
woman
the furthest white is it's in front
i can't tell it looks like her head is
in a shadow
okay can you tell what color hair the
person
that's uh
middle but in the back
no same everything looks like they're
the tops of their heads are in shadows
all right and you believe that the one
to the left is amber heard
um no i
i believe that that's the one that's
doing most of the talking
[Music]
and the other requirements as well
it must have been like a double column
okay who's amber
did you see anybody acknowledge that
they identify themselves as amber
it looks like it was the girl sitting
furthest away from me furthest away from
the camera okay and how would you
describe the lighting in there
uh pretty
dim and uh dark you said earlier you
thought we were 10 to 15 feet away how
much would you estimate now that you are
looking at this on body cam how far away
are you from the two women
i would still say it's in that range did
you get a clear look at any of these
three women
um
i can't remember
and did you ask to have any of them come
out into the lighting so that you could
take a better look at them to see if
potentially they might have injuries
no
what perception did you have
about the level of cooperation of these
four individuals with your answer in
this call
a pretty
low level of cooperation
okay
now can we uh
figuring out example number five
it's the other video i just want to run
through both of them because there's a
little bit of a different angle in the
two
oh
[Music]
penthouse 30.
[Laughter]
females
[Laughter]
you guys let
york or something yeah she could
probably call it twice okay
can you just talk to your wife and make
sure it's called it's not my first
different conversation
what is
[Laughter]
uh
is
all right cool
everything's all good then
all right
[Laughter]
so
now showing you defendants exhibit
number five
and let me just stop here for a minute
does this appear to be
the video cam from your video cam
uh yes
[Music]
three
[Laughter]
thank you
okay
[Laughter]
hello
[Music]
i'll go get the business card from the
cops
just because we got another call when we
came again
[Laughter]
who's amber
so i'm just stopping here again um
on these three women uh you had
indicated before the woman that's
leaning forward here that she's in the
middle is that correct uh it appears
that way and you think she's the one who
did most of the talking correct uh yeah
right now she was the one talking
okay and do you believe that amber is
the one in the back behind her
yes
um
are you able to see the right side of
amber's face
from this camera view it looks like
she's kind of facing uh straight towards
me
so i would have been able to see the
right side of her face from there
would you have been able to see it
clearly
due to the low lighting probably not
very clearly
johnny
is definitely not
can you tell how much hair amber has
covering the right side of her face to
your pictures
uh no it
looks like uh
from this camera view
most of the time like half of her head
is blocked from the woman in front of
her
can you tell whether she's wearing any
makeup
no
everything about good then
all right
do you recall looking for any injuries
in the faces of the three women
um no
[Laughter]
now uh officer gatlin do you recall
seeing two dogs in the house
yes
they were running around pretty freely
yes
and when you say that
would you be able to sit in here today
say that the person in these three
photos defendants seven eight and nine
is the same person that was sitting on
that sofa in the back are you able to
draw that connection
um
no i don't recall
do you
do you disagree with my description of
what's in this picture no i was stating
that i didn't observe that when i was
inside the apartment are you
able to testify
whether amber heard was the victim of
domestic violence by mr depp on may 21
2016.
uh based on our investigation it
appeared as if she was not
your investigation of what
based on her refusing to
give any statement on what had occurred
and at the time
we did not observe any
any visible or verifiable injuries
to her
anything else
not that i can recall
right so did you interview any of the
three other individuals in the apartment
no
did you ask any of the individuals to
give you a statement about what
transpired
i believe the female that was sitting in
the middle of the three
told us that everything was fine and
that the other officers had already
conducted an investigation on the
incident prior to our arrival
did you ask
that individual to give you a statement
outside of that no
did you take that individual
aside and try to interview her without
the others present
no
why not
as i just stated uh
everybody there had
told us that the officers who had
responded a couple hours before us had
conducted the investigation
and this is uh
our call is still stemming from that
incident
and there's been there have been no
change in the circumstance since then
do you know whether officer science and
officer hadden took any of the
individuals aside and interviewed them
no
did you at any point
ask amber heard to come forward and
examine her in the light to see if she
had any injuries
no
did you take a flashlight
just to see if she had any visible
injuries to her face or her body
no
did you ask amber heard if she had any
injuries
no
i'm asking whether you're in a position
as a police officer
to testify under oath
that johnny depp did not commit any
abuse of amber heard on may 21 2016. i
don't believe i'm in the position to
testify whether he did or did not
because i was not there when the
incident potentially occurred
okay
and you didn't conduct your own
independent investigation correct
outside of the female telling us that
everything was fine and uh the male
answer the door
that uh told us that the other officers
had already came and talked to everybody
and uh
she told us they checked the both the
two apartments
so
i felt at that time sufficient that
as i stated there's uh no change in the
circumstance from the previous call
so we did not go further into
investigation
and that's the extent of your
investigation correct correct did you do
that
that night on may 21 2016. did you do
anything
other than what
we have looked at on the video camera in
connection with investigating whether
johnny depp committed domestic violence
with ample heart on may 21 2016.
no
do you know
whether johnny depp committed domestic
violence of amber heard on may 21 2016.
now
sorry your next witness
alejandro romero
alejandro romero
and if i might your honor this is
another one that begins with questioning
by counsel for ms heard and later on
switches to questioning by counsel for
mr depp
okay thank you
romero will you please state your name
and address for the record
my name i'm sorry my name is alejandro
romero
i go by alex
what is your current occupation
i'll work on the front desk so that you
trinkle eastern columbia building
and is that for the action property
management company
that's correct
how long have you been employed at the
eastern columbia building
approximately 13 years
and could you please describe what kind
of work you do for the eastern plunder
building
most of it is just access control and i
deal with a lot of residents regarding
their packages
and food delivery
okay and have you done that pretty much
the whole 10 years
that's correct
i'm going to take you back to 2015 and
2016 for a moment
how many people how many people would
you say
would go through the building on any
particular day in that time
and it's invisible
i cannot say a number
because uh there's there's 147 units in
the building
and there's
uh
there are visitors guests friends
uh
actually we used to send delivery people
up
we don't sell it anymore because of the
kobe uh but i cannot tell your number
there's
thousands of people probably
have you ever met johnny depp
i saw him a couple of times
do you remember what mr depp was wearing
on any of those equations
nope
do you remember what you read
nope
do you remember
what headgear he was wearing he was
wearing a scarf or a hat
[Music]
no
do you remember whether mr depp was
wearing any makeup or island
[Music]
do you know whether mr depp
has had ever been physically violent
with amber heard and by this i mean
hitting punching throwing objects at her
kicking her head butting her you know
one way or the other whether mr depp
ever did that to miss her
nope
do you ever seen mr deb
uh slam things around or
be angry
no i have never seen him like that
i'm gonna ask you some questions now
about amber fern
when did you first meet amber
[Music]
i believe
she was passing on the lobby
i met at the front desk
i got interact more with uh her sister
with me i believe her that's her name
and uh
her good friend uh raquel rocky
and uh but amber i only see him like
once in a while when she was uh
sometimes used to get packages
do you recall whether ms heard became a
resident
sometime around march 2016
[Music]
don't remember could you tell me one way
or the other
i just can't remember like i said it's
been so long i just don't remember and
like i know you guys sent me the papers
to review and i'm gonna be honest i
don't didn't want to review him because
he's been so long he's like
i
just don't want to deal with this
anymore
yes i went through the witness statement
and it's everything that is written
there that's what i said
that was
so during the time between 2015 and
2016 how many times would you say total
that you interacted with amber
for a whole year i i don't i can give
you a number because it could be like
probably i'll see you i would probably
celebrate for uh
three times in one day probably i'll say
like five times and probably i will
never see for a whole week so i don't
have like there's not never been a
routine
okay
how would you describe amber heard's
interactions with you were they friendly
did she smile at you would she talk with
you she was really friendly
she would always smile
and but she we never had like um
like a interaction with
us that's really close relationship like
uh like i do with some of the other
residents
she never told me anything of her
problems she never stopped by talk about
her personal life she never did that
they're asking you about
uh
a date that you recall seeing amber
heard
on may 25 2016. do you see that
yes i do
you said probably i just can't remember
the days i've got a really bad memory
for dates did you see that
yep
so
mr romero would you at any time be able
to remember
what type of clothing amber heard was
wearing
from one of her
events
nope i don't remember
would you remember on any daily basis
what type of hairstyle she was there
no
would you remember on any type of basis
what type of
bag she was amber heard was carrying
no
would you be able to say uh whether she
amber heard was dressed up or casual on
any given day
no
would you be able to
say
whether she was what type of makeup
amber bird was wearing on youtube
no
would you be able to say for example
whether amber heard had on concealer or
foundation
on any given day
no
would you be able to say whether amber
heard had on blush
or powder on any given day
no would you be able to say whether
amber heard had a mascara or eyeliner on
any given day
no
how about eyebrow pencil or lip pencil
no
do you
have any memorable memories
of
amber heard
uh
wearing a particular type of makeup with
a type of outfit
no
if you were asked
to describe uh any characteristics of
amber or heard from two days earlier
without knowing you were going to be
asked would you be able to testify to
any of those what she was wearing what
her makeup was what her hairstyle was
no i probably won't remember
when is the first time
that you recall
anyone saying anything to you
about the police being called
at the ec building
because of the domestic dispute between
mr depp and amber
well
to answer your question
whatever happened it happened on a
saturday i don't work saturday when i
got there on monday
they asked me oh you heard what happened
and said no what happened
so that's how i find out
then i went to the i went to the cameras
to see what was what was going on then
as soon as i saw johnny depp on the
camera on the elevator just walking back
and forward on the camera in the
elevator and said okay i know
that was tim and that's all i knew
but i was never i was never i was not
there and that started when that
happened i believe that
that whatever they happened they said it
happened and when they called the police
i believe it wasn't it wasn't a saturday
and i was not there
okay
do you recall who told you that on that
monday following
okay
as a matter of fact i think it was one
of the residents because they approached
me and they said uh there was a lot of
noise because the person was working out
on the gym that's next to the penthouse
they heard a punching noise and that's
it and i that's why i checked the camera
and said and when i looked at the
cameras and i saw johnny like i say was
just walking back and forward and the
elevator
and i said like okay all right okay now
i'll try to figure it out and i didn't
say anything more i turn up the camera
and that's it
so the first part of that who's somebody
was working out and heard noise
i was working out on the gym
and heard the noise to hear some a lot
of noise in the hallway
because it's really rare to hear
anything because most of the time
uh the penthouse level is is really
quiet
okay do you remember who the person was
in the gym
that heard a lot of noise in the
penthouse that name
that's correct i do remember the person
who is it
ah
i remember the person he's been a
resident of the building for a long time
i just don't remember i don't remember
her name
and where is the gym
in comparison to
the penthouse
that's owned by mr deb
like i said johnny depp owns all the
penthouses on the um
clock the gym is sick the gym of the
eastern columbia building is just in
front of one of the penthouses
you actually could see it through the
window
you can see the gym through a window of
the penthouse and you can see the
penthouse through a window of the gym
you can see the
gym to
one of the windows to the penthouse
and it has a
patio that leads to the gym
and also that is to live to the gym
okay
and
this tenant if you if you think of her
name while you're you know even if we're
asking another question please let me
know this this tenant this is a resident
there right that saw this
yeah i believe her name is uh shawna
and so she told you she heard a lot of
noise
that's correct
did she describe
anything voices
any objects anything like that
no she just said there was a noise
uh just noise
and she was just surprised because like
i said it's always really quiet
okay
and so she wanted to know what happened
and so you went to the video cameras to
look at
video how did you know when to look for
them
because she got the time
she got the time that she was working
out
that's why i i steered out the track the
time on the camera it looked
and then when i saw as soon as i saw it
like i said johnny depp walking back and
forth the other i turned off the camera
and i figured out okay this is what
happened
i figured out put we wanted to together
i thought okay
when you said you figured out what
happened after you saw johnny depp in
the elevator what did you figure out had
happened
i feared how that was that was that's
why they call the cops
mr romero i'm going to ask you
to look at this is a video clip
marked as romero exhibit number eight
okay
and it shows the
date and time
near the bottom do you recognize this as
the elevator at ecb building
that's good mr romero you're nodding is
this the video that you remember looking
at after shauna told you that she heard
the noise that night
that's correct
and that's mr depp
all right do you recognize the other two
men in the elevator
i recognize uh the guy in front of the
elevator button that's his personal
bodyguard
the other guy uh i've seen him before
but uh
i never interact with him
if i did i don't remember
you said he looked at it
yeah he looks agitated like he was
walking back and forth he took his
jacket his body language is it was a
different about than before
most of the time he's really calm
he's just like really happy person
this is the first time i saw him like
that
and then you go to the next so then you
say wednesday may 25th
at approximately 10 30 miss heard walked
into the lobby accompanied by ms raquel
pennington that's the person you called
rocky earlier do you remember her
yes that's correct
okay and you said that
bird approached you to ask you for the
key to her unit which you gave
and you said we did not discuss anything
else at that time
all right
ms heard stood approximately three feet
away from you
i did not notice any bruises cuts
swelling red marks or any other injuries
of any kind on this bird's face do you
see that
all right
okay
but you weren't looking for bruises cut
swelling red marks or any other injuries
on this bird's face that night were you
i was not looking for any marks or
bruises or anything
uh
but
something like that it will be really
noticeable but i guess you know
i wasn't looking
i was more focusing on what my job
studies was like getting the key and
also this
i gave him the key and they were talking
about i told her you know what your dog
i was talking with raquel because her
dog got out of her unit
and that was one one of my christians i
would tell you know what i saw your dog
was outside he didn't want me to get get
too close to it
so it's still out there
you know on the penthouse area
that dog will be fine because it's not
like i said it's always really quiet and
mr deb owns everything up there so
it'll be fine so that was one of my
concerns that was my job i was just
taking care of that
i was not trying to say oh let me see
your face no
so and that's where i'm going to follow
up do you remember what miss heard was
wearing that night
no
do you remember whether she was dressed
up
no
do you remember where she was coming
from that she was coming home at 10 30
at night with his opinion
no i don't remember they mentioned to me
she was actually she was on the phone
she was with raquel in front of me we
were talking about it and then she left
to the lobby
where she was still on the phone
i was focusing more on raquel because
she they were i was telling about her
dog
okay do you remember what hairstyle this
herd had that night
nope
do you know what type of makeup amber
heard was wearing that night
no
can you tell me whether she was wearing
concealer or foundation
no would you tell me whether she was
wearing blush
no
could you tell me whether she was
wearing any type of
any kind of eye makeup
no
so
who
wrote the sentence i did not notice any
bruises pets swelling red marks or any
other injuries of any kind in this
bird's face i'm pretty sure if i want to
see something like that how would it say
something
mr romero
[Music]
she was just standing in front of me
i'm asking specifically i did not notice
any bruises cuts swelling red marks or
any other injuries of any kind to ms
bird's face
that's what i said
i didn't sew any marks or bruises on her
face
that's
they asked me if i remember seeing
anything and so i just don't recall
seeing any marks on brothers because she
was just sitting in front of me
i just don't remember anything anything
you just don't remember
how it would be so obvious like someone
had like a black eye i would have like
whoa you know
i would have seen that and i would
remember because
it's something that you will all you
will see
you're like so noticeable like you will
all like you will remember but when i
was there talking to her she was like
three feet away from me she was right in
front of me i just don't remember seeing
any marks bruises or anything
but you don't know whether she was
wearing makeup to cover it do you
no i don't know no
i
she was wearing any makeup try to cover
it probably
you know the
probably would you probably will cover
any bruise
but you cannot cover the swelling
were you looking for swelling
no
i could say i was not looking for
anything in fact you were spending more
time talking to rocky about her dog were
you not
that's correct but i gotta i gotta have
it up uh when i'm [ __ ] someone i look
into their eyes
and when i was talking to
amber and rocky i always look into their
eyes
and i will probably wouldn't notice like
any swollen
or bruised like i said
i would probably would notice it's fair
to say mr romero
that you can't say that amber heard
had injuries or did not have injuries
that day
on the 25th
i don't remember
i wouldn't probably remember the swollen
but i didn't saw anything
i don't
don't remember
and you don't remember seeing anything
right but do you remember
even looking
i remember
i remember okay i'm i'm really sorry
but i remember
i got to tell the whole story how they
got there
before they got they went and get the
keys they come down they say somebody
tried to get into my unit
there's scratches on my door say
hey like
oh
i'm really sorry but
who
will think it's gonna get into your unit
because it saw some scratches on the
door like
what four inches
above the door because the dog was
scratching the door was trying to get in
and they thought about someone's trying
to break into their their unit
i said on my head i would say you're
really you think someone's trying to get
into your unit
there's scratches like four inches above
your the floor on your door that was the
dog trying to get into the unit
they were so afraid oh someone's trying
to get into my ears like oh come on
really
and i actually when they asked me to go
inside the unit just to check room by
room to make sure that no one was there
so i did that as part of my job make
sure they're safe but
i like really i didn't understand why
they want me to do that
like
oh i don't know
i i just so stressed out because of this
i just don't want to deal with this
anymore i'm tired i don't want to deal
with this court case i everybody got
problems
and i don't want to deal with this no
more
i don't know how i don't want to put
this
any more words
the interaction you just testified about
with amber heard and rocky pennington
talking about the dog and going up and
checking out the penthouse none of that
was on video footage correct
correct that we don't have cameras in
the videos um sorry we don't have
cameras not the hallways
we don't have cameras on the hallway
i'm gonna
show you
uh what has been marked as romero
exhibit number one it's a deposition
that you was taking of you on july 19
2016. now that's approximately two
months
after
the may 21 2006
incident um and i do you recall giving
that
deposition
16 probably dude i don't remember
okay
i'm going to take you to page 35.
a little bit more
you were asked
this is the same incident that you're
talking about now okay
and it's talking about okay you spoke
with amber at the front desk later
started the lobby later went upstairs
with her
it says the question at line six i just
want to go back for a second here you
said several times in answer to my
questions that you didn't recall seeing
any marks on amber's face
when you say you didn't recall seeing
any of those marks any marks did you
mean that you didn't see any marks on
her face
and your answer then was i say that
because when i saw amber i was not
looking to see anything on her face i
was not looking to see anything do you
recall giving that testimony under oath
back at that time two months after the
incident
yes i don't i remember because like i
said i was
i always make eye contact with someone
i'm talking to
but i'm not looking to find something
like like oh your makeup is wrong uh
you
you haven't uh have changed your
eyebrows
or your
eyelashes are not even or
i'm not looking for anything i'm just
looking at their eyes and i look i'm not
looking for anything else but if i see
something i will probably will remember
if you saw something right
yeah i would have probably would see
like if she had a swollen like if she
was wearing makeup probably would
expensing the swan i probably will
remember that but i was not looking for
anything i was like oh you know
how swollen was amber on the 25th of may
how swollen was her cheekbone
according to the pictures
i've been seeing right now that you're
showing me
it was pretty swollen i will probably
will remember that how many
days later did you see her from that
swelling
it wasn't a wednesday that was from time
to wednesday right how many days
would it be fair to say
that you cannot have to fight one way or
the other whether ever heard was
domestically
abused by johnny depp on may 21 2016.
i can't i cannot say that i will not
agree to testify against
anyone of domestic violence because i
was not there i didn't see anything i
didn't hear anything i was not there i
was never there i was probably hundreds
of miles away
and got no idea what happened that day
and do you remember
that there was pictures
of wine a glass of wine and bottle of
wine wine stains on the floor outside
of the
uh in the hallway of the penthouse from
may 21st 2016.
i remember trying to mark that i gotta
say it was wine
all right
well
you're good
ladies and gentlemen the next portion of
this deposition contains questions asked
by council for mr deb
you sit here today
when you saw her at the front desk on
march 25th
you didn't see any bruising correct
correct
and you didn't see uh
that's correct i didn't see any muscle
bruises
she didn't see any swelling either did
you mr romero
that's correct
no swallowing she was only
and she was only three or four feet away
from you correct
correct and you were looking right into
her face squarely correct
correct
and the lighting was
good at the front desk correct
it was so good that had she had any
bruises swelling or marks on her face
you would have noticed that correct
and then later that
later that same day and you testified to
this already today
later that same day you went
up the elevator with miss hurd and miss
pennington
uh in connection with their request for
you to check the penthouse correct
and during that entire
period of time
taking them up to the penthouse walking
through the penthouse and then finally
you leaving and going back to your desk
you did not
you
looked you looked at miss heard during
that time period
that's
correct
and you looked her in the face squarely
in the face correct correct
and you didn't notice any swelling
correct
correct
i'm sorry
correct
i didn't saw anything
did
did you see did you see any swelling
no
do you see any bruises
nope
see any
face of any kind
no marks at all
okay and again just to repeat when you
were
previously when you were confronted i
can report the faith did you see me uh
swelling on her face
nope
nope did you see any marks of any kind
on her face
no marks at all
and how was the light down when you were
at the reception and you were looking at
her and didn't see any of this how was
the lighting
the ladder is actually pretty pretty
good
it's not it's not stuck at all
she went
apart
three to four feet apart
were you looking for square in the face
right okay
and when you were up in the penthouse
and you
were looking her square in the face how
far apart were you from here then we
actually were pretty close to each other
uh
she was probably next just next to me
just she was telling me like going to
this uh this um
this room so i need to pass
right in front of her
and
do you recall
seeing
any bruises swelling redness or any
marks on miss hurt's face on may 24th
2016.
i'll see if anything
ladies and gentlemen at this point the
remainder of this deposition of this
witness uh contains questions by council
for ms heard
i'm going to talk a little bit about
the video clips that
mr depp's attorney
showed you
um
i'm going to ask you first of all mr
presidio showed you a number
of video clips from
may 24th do you recall that
may 24th
yes
yep not tuesday but in fact you don't
recall seeing amber heard on may 24th
correct
i don't remember i don't even remember
what i got for breakfast
okay
well let's pull up
exhibit number one
let's stay on page 17 that's a good
place
um
this is your deposition from july 19
2016. did you recall that
nineteen yeah
okay and that's that was three in the
morning
okay
and it said here
uh
did you so saturday was the 21st did you
work that day no did you work sunday may
22nd no did you work may 23rd yes on may
23rd while you were working did you see
amber at any time i don't recall seeing
question did you work on tuesday may
24th yes i did and
and on tuesday may 24th at any time did
you see amber i don't recall seeing her
do you remember that being your
testimony two months after the events
yeah
i just wanna recall i don't remember
okay um and then i while we're here now
mr uh presidio had you go through a
number of video clips and ask you a
bunch of questions about whether you
start swelling whether you saw red marks
whether you saw all kinds of other
things
but in fact
i'm going to ask you and tell me if you
need me to bring up the videos and
replay them
can you tell me
what type of makeup amber heard was
wearing in any of those videos
the hollow cameras i can't tell you
i really know she was wearing
can you tell me whether amber heard was
wearing concealer in any of those videos
no
can you tell me whether amber heard was
wearing any foundation in any of those
videos
no i can't tell you
can you tell me whether amber heard was
wearing any blush in any of those videos
no
can you tell me whether amber heard was
wearing any powder on in any of those no
no but
she looks really pale
well
do you know what shade of concealer or
foundation or powder ms bird uses or
used at that time
no
okay
um so you don't know whether ms heard
was wearing makeup in every one of those
video clips correct
all right
enough i want to try to move along so
the
incident was may 21st 2016.
you saw her the night of may 25th
correct
she said
amber heard hundreds of times
well she was that never heard treat you
well and was she friendly to you in each
of these hundreds of times
yes yes i i'm not gonna say no because
she was really always nice all right
be nice all right this is my last
question you testified in response to mr
presidio's questions um that you
testified truthfully in all of these
occasions did you testify truthfully
truthfully to everything that you
testified in response to my questions
today
that's correct uh i i did
all right it's a good time to break for
lunch uh we'll just break a little early
so just don't talk to anybody don't do
any outside research and we'll see you
at two o'clock okay
thank you
all right
that was the first i'm sorry
i will say you're on that is the most
bizarre episode yeah okay all right
see i've just never seen that before
i've seen a lot of things but i've just
never seen him driving that yeah that
did it all right so um
we will come back at two uh is there
anything preliminary before we get to
the next deposition you'll work through
them and then if i come back at two we
should be able to take care of it pretty
quickly yes
okay all right great we'll come back at
you thank you
what are we doing first we're doing
careers
are we ready for the jury
okay we are your honor thank you
um
all right thank you thank you for your
patience ladies and gentlemen all right
your next witness
plaintiff calls christian carino your
honor christian carrino and um as with a
number of the other depositions this one
will start with questioning by miss
herd's counsel
and
one at some point switch over to
questioning by counsel for mr dutt all
right and what's the how do you spell
the last name just for me just okay c
a
r
i
n
o thank you
an address for the record and you may
use your business address if you've done
more competition
christian carino and the work address is
2 000 avenue of stars in century city
and and that is in california correct
and what is your current occupation
i'm a talent agent
and
could you give me just a very brief
description of your educational
background and work experience
sure i have a ba from the university of
massachusetts
and
my work background is i've been at caa
for approximately 16 years and before
that
i had a
[Music]
12-year
run with two different advertising
agencies in new york
and who were those
advertising agencies in new york
and mccann erickson
right
um now you indicated that you were a
talent agent can you please describe
what that means
um i represent
multiple clients and brands
in transactions in the entertainment
space
and
when you say in the entertainment space
what are you including
just the different genres of
entertainment everything from
um motion picture to television to
books to licensing to
um modeling
all the different areas that the agency
is
operates in
as a talent agent
representing multiple clients
what types of services do you perform
for them and what is the objective
okay yep
i
i conduct transact business transactions
on behalf of clients and brands
in the entertainment space
and
what does that mean
[Music]
it means
it means
i
organize pitch
transact
in
contractual
agreements between talent
and
studios
talent and
brands
entertainment platforms and individuals
brands and individuals
do you represent any actors
i do
work with
every different group of
talent within the agency
and for each person it's different
the business that i personally oversee
for them
so in some cases
i
am
negotiating
contractual agreements
for a music artist to
go to las vegas
in some cases i'm transacting
an agreement
for an artist to have a relationship
with a brand
in some cases
it's
a an artist with a
platform like netflix
it
it spans the the general
platform
capabilities that the agency has overall
is one of the objectives of your
representation
uh to build
uh the careers of the individuals you
represent
yes
did you have any
conversations with mr waldman in which
you
expressed
any thoughts or opinions
on
how you believed any litigation was
having an effect on mr depp's reputation
or career
yes
how many times
one that i can recall and when was that
i had no idea years ago
if you expressed to mr waldman that the
sooner the litigation was over the
better for mr depp
what were you thinking when you said
that why did you think that
i think any time somebody somebody's in
litigation publicly
it is at a minimum a distraction to
that person's
career
and in
a lot of cases
it's
it negatively
impacts
that person because there's the tension
drawn to them
that
uh it is outside of what people want to
know about that person
and
what do you mean by it distract from the
career
i mean that
the
with somebody who is well known
people don't want to hear
they're in a lawsuit
with anybody about anything
why not
because that's just not what they want
to
know or hear
news about
people
[Music]
and why do you believe that
based on my
experience in
this world for the past 16 years
and when you say it negatively impacts
what do you mean by that
people don't want to hear that
the people that they look up to
are in
litigation
do you also believe that that impacts
career decisions by producers directors
[Music]
companies your brands
because the general public doesn't want
to hear that
people that they look up to
are in litigation
and when it
the more oxygen it takes up
in
the overall
news
or coverage of an individual
and the less focused it is on that
person's career
the less interested
studios brands
the general public becomes in that
person
and therefore less opportunities
yes
when you express
to adam waldman that
your opinion that the sooner the
litigation was over from mr depp the
better
what did mr waldman say
to be honest i don't recall exactly what
he said but something to
something like
we're
gonna
get this over with as fast as we can
carrito i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as carino
exhibit number we'll keep it labeled for
um
do you believe that the mandel lawsuit
posed a distraction to mr depp's career
i don't know
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as
carino
deposition exhibit number five
and as you can see here it's an article
june 21st 2017.
[Music]
the hollywood gossip
do you recall
that coming up during that time frame
that issue
have you read or heard of the rolling
stones
yes
have you read or heard of gq
yes
mr carino i'm going to ask you to take a
look
at what has been marked as carino
deposition exhibit number two
and it's
rolling stone
publication on june 21 2018
do you see that
yes
do you ever read this article
parts of it
aware
of whether
this article
in the rolling stone june 2018 that's
reflected in carino exhibit number two
impacted in a negative way mr depp's
reputation or career
elena i i don't think it's possible to
ask anybody
that that question
without
having done research among the people
who read a specific article
if you're asking
my opinion
about whether an article like this or
this particular article in my opinion
would have a positive or negative effect
on somebody's
you know career
i could potentially answer that
but as to definitively whether an
article
has or has not had an impact on
somebody's career
nobody can answer that question
without research
specifically
mr carmino i think we were just going to
start looking at the carino exhibit
number three
this is an article that was published in
november of 2018
do you
recall
reading this at some point
what publication is that
uh this is gq
um i
probably read part of it but i don't
remember
you had any direct contact with ed white
or his company
yes
what is the nature of your contact with
red white in his company
payment on
on
deals where
johnny was owed money
bill collecting
when you say bill collecting was it
collecting on on your behalf or was it
trying to collect from studios or
companies
uh the latter
and so what would your involvement be in
those circumstances
um ed
on occasion reached out to me to ask
about
the
timing of a payment that was owed to
johnny
[Music]
were you able to answer those questions
um
i think in all cases i just referred him
to somebody who worked for me to
find out what the payment schedule was
other than these
occasions where ed white would reach out
to you
to ask when paying the time you payment
did you have any other
connection or communication with ed
white or his company in connection with
johnny depp no
were you familiar with jake bloom
yes
do you know whether mr bloom ever
represented mr depp yes
what was your understanding of the
nature of back representation
he was his lawyer
did you ever talk to jake boom
yes
on how many occasions
did you speak with jake bloom
relating to mr jeff
i have no idea
was it pretty frequently
what does that mean
well is it more than 10
are you asking me if i had
approximately
10 conversations with jake
over the duration of our relationship
yes
i actually asked if you had more than 10
i wasn't asking you if it was exactly
10. okay
i mean i'm guessing that
it was probably less than 10 in total
was mr bloom still representing mr depp
when you started representing mr depp i
believe so but i'm not sure
and when did you start representing mr
depp
i believe
it was
in
late 2016.
mr um carino are you looking at
something to be able to refresh your
recollection i am
what do you have in front of you
a node
that i made to myself of of
uh the date
of
when johnny was a client and i think i
wrote down october 2016.
do you have a recollection of the
context
of your discussions with mr william
yes
my recollection of the conversations i
had with
jake were
in regards to
uh getting
uh
johnny and
jake to
meet and work out whatever the issues
were
um
around their disagreement
so you were trying to broker
if you will a
discussion between them to try to
resolve their issues
right
were you successful in that
i don't remember whether they ever got
together and
and
met about it to be honest
now i'm going to show you what has been
marked as deposition carino deposition
exhibit number seven
and this is
a um
lawsuit that was filed on october 17
2017.
were you aware of this litigation being
filed by
mr depp
on his behalf against bloomberg
gamer etc
yes
and were you involved in any way in this
litigation
no
do you know
one way or the other
whether
the filing of and the ongoing litigation
associated with this lawsuit
had any negative impact on mr
depp's
reputation career
i said now elaine
do you recall whether there was any
publicity surrounding
this litigation that's reflected
uh in the complaint that's
number seven
are you asking me if i'm aware if
the jade bloom litigation was made
public
yes
yes
and in addition to being made public
do you recall whether there was po
publicity surrounding the jacob
litigation yes
and do you recall whether there was
publicity surrounding the mandel
litigation
yes
mr carino i'm going to ask you what has
been march's deposition exhibit number
10.
uh and in this particular one we have
this is the
article that
it was written in the sun
times
that
was the uh
beginning if you will of the uk
lawsuit do you have a recollection of
seeing that
no
did you ever read it
i don't know i'd have to
i don't know i'm sure i've read at least
part of it if it's the
the original document that caused the
sun
legal issues
now the date on this one is april 27
2018.
do you see that on there
mr crater i'm going to ask you what has
been marked as deposition
carino deposition exhibit number 11
and it's dated june 13 2018. it's hard
to see that little stamp there at that
but it was filed on june 13
2018 um
and it's mr depp filing the news group
newspaper is limited who was the son and
then dan wooten
were you aware
that mr depp brought this lawsuit in the
uk against the sun and mr wharton
yeah
mr creator i'm going to ask you to take
a look at what has been marked now as
carino exhibit number 12.
this is a
this was published in the washington
post
on december 18 2018
were you aware of this article
yes
yes
mr karina when i asked you whether you
were aware one way or the other
whether
this
lawsuit that's reflected in
exhibit number 11
had a negative impact on mr
depp's reputation and career
you answered no what did you mean by
that
i meant that
there isn't a way for any individual to
know
whether the filing of a document had an
impact on somebody's career positive or
negative without
specific research conducted
in
exactly that
case
the same as in the facts that you
because you haven't researched it you
don't know whether it impacted mr depp's
reputation or career correct
i i believe
i stated that unless someone had done
research specifically about the filing
of this document and its impact one way
or the other
it's impossible to answer the question
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as carino number 14.
this is the lawsuit that mr depp filed
against
ms heard
do you believe
that the filing of this lawsuit
reflected in carino
deposition exhibit number 14
and the attendant publicity has had a
negative impact
on the
reputation and career of mr death
no
and why not
because i've stated previously
it's not about
the filing
of a lawsuit it's about the coverage
i mean you're asking me what my opinion
is of what johnny's reputation is
today is is that
what you're asking
my opinion of what johnny's reputation
today is
one of the finest actors of his
generation
has
in your opinion has mr depp's reputation
changed
at any point from october 2016
to the present
if you're asking me if what i defined as
his reputation has
changed in terms of his being viewed as
one of
the best actors of his generation
i i would say no
so just so i'm clear that i understand
your answer
in your
opinion
mr depp's reputation
[Music]
is that he is one of the finest actors
of his generation and that has been his
reputation since you started
representing him in october 2016 it
still is today and it hasn't changed
during that time frame is that correct
the view on his acting ability
has not changed
well i'm taking your definition
of reputation you said what they are
known for
so i'm taking that
specific
definition and i'm asking is there
anything other than
that mr depp is one of the finest actors
of his generation
that he is known for
that has changed between october 2016
and the president
the only way i can answer that is as it
relates to his professional capabilities
that has not changed
is there something that has changed that
doesn't relate to his professional
capabilities
i don't know how to answer that elaine
using your definition of reputation
which is what
a person is known for
is there any aspect
of what mr depp is known for
that has changed between october 2016
and the present
it's
i've
stated what i think his reputation is
and i've stated
that in my opinion
his professional reputation
as it relates to the quality of his
acting abilities
has remained unchanged
do you
make any distinction between personal
and professional reputation
yes
and what is that distinction
the difference between
what somebody does on screen
and
off screen
what is your opinion of
what mr depp was known for off-screen
when you started representing him in
october 2016.
i think
what he was known
for
off-screen
was
a shroud of mystery of
who he was because he was not visible
to
the public
and that was back in october 2016.
uh i don't have a specific date for that
all right but when you started
representing him that was your sense
yes okay
did that change
over time
yes
and
in what way did it change
[Music]
it
changed with the exposure of
that that came with the
lawsuits
[Music]
and the losses that we're talking about
are the ones
that
we've
already taken a look at
exhibit 4
7
8 9
11
and 15.
no i mean 14
i mean
i'm not talking about any
one or two
specifically
in general
do you believe that mr depp
is still a shroud of mystery not visible
to the public
no
and when did that change
i don't know exactly when
would you say it was cumulative over the
period of time as a result of all of the
litigation and the publicity ensuing
probably
is there any one specific litigation
that you believe most significantly
impacted
on mr depp's personal reputation no
longer being a shroud of mystery and not
visible to the public
my opinion is that amber's accusations
would have had the most dramatic impact
on
his off-screen reputation
i'm not talking about
any
one specific
accusation
when you say amber's accusations
what do you mean by
that i i mean the things that
she's accused johnny of doing
both
in
that have been made public
now
those accusations were made public in
the divorce back in 2016 correct
i don't know exactly
how or when they were made public
given
that you believe amber's accusation
would have had the most dramatic impact
on mr depp's off-screen reputation
would
amber have been filing the divorce
action
and obtaining a domestic violence
restraining order have had a dramatic
impact
on mr depp's off-screen reputation
i think the only way i can answer that
is
by saying i don't think
filing for divorce
would have any impact whatsoever
and
i'm actually not familiar with the
lawsuit to get the restraining order so
i don't know
exactly what's in there
but
if
that was based on
claims of or accusations of
abuse
then that
in my opinion would have a negative
impact on johnny's offscreen reputation
mr carino we were talking about uh
amber's accusations
uh and your view that those would have
the most dramatic impact
on
mr
depp's
offspring reputation
and you were talking about her
accusations of domestic abuse and
violence correct
yes
were you aware that the dan wooten
article published in the sun
included
specific accusations
by amber heard of domestic about
violence and abuse by mr death
the sun case is that what you're asking
about yeah well first the article itself
that was in the paper the
why is jk rowling genuinely happy
about employing mr deb the wife peter
yes
okay
and you're aware that
the
the litigation the lawsuit including the
particulars of the claim brought by mr
depp
included
the accusations uh by amber heard of
domestic violence and abuse
by mr deaf correct
yes
given that the mandel lawsuit included
uh
accusations by amber heard of domestic
violence
by mr depp against her
are you able to say how much
of
mr depp's off-screen reputation was in
that impacted by the mandela box
now
you were aware
that the op ed
by dan wooten and the son
included
accusations
by amber of domestic violence against mr
depp right
yes
um
are you aware one way or the other
how much mr depp's
off-screen reputation was impacted
by the
complaint that was filed in this case
that
contained amber heard's accusations of
domestic violence and abuse by mr depp
no
are you aware of how much
mr depp's offspring reputation
was impacted
as a result of
the op ed in washington post from amber
perth
no
are you aware of how much
mr deb's off-screen reputation was
impacted
by the accusations
included in the waldman tweet
on may 220
of the op-ed
are you aware of any
wall
or opportunity
that mr depp
lost
as a result of the op-ed by dan wooten
no
are you aware of any role or
and when i'm saying opportunity any kind
of business opportunity uh that mr depp
lost as a result of the particulars of
claim
that mr depp filed
you aware of
any role or business opportunities that
mr depp lost as a result of
the op-ed by ambro third in the
washington post
okay are you aware of any roles or
business opportunities that mr depp lost
as a result of the weldment tweets in
may 2020 relating to amber's out there
is there any other
goal
or business opportunity
that mr depp
has lost
since
you started representing him in october
2016.
and i'm saying
i would say
his
um
i would say yes
what
the pirates the the next pirates movie
do you remember which one that was
six seven i'm not sure what the number
is
hit six i think pirate six is the ones
you have to come up with
um and
why
what is your understanding of why
mr depp's
lost pirate six
my opinion
is that it was related to the
accusations
um
that amber has made
and what is your opinion based on
excuse me
what is your opinion based on
um
conversations with
colleagues and studios
i'm sorry i didn't quite hear you
conversations with studios and
other executives both
internal and external
when you say related to the accusations
that were made by amber heard against mr
deb are you talking about accusations of
domestic violence and abuse by mr death
yes
how many conversations have you had with
studio and other executives
i have no idea
more than five more than ten
i don't know about more than 10 probably
between 5 and 10.
who do you recall speaking with
at studios
or other executives
um
jerry bruckheimer
probably mostly jerry and then
colleagues at caa
when did you first have any
conversations with jerry buchanan about
pirate sex in this yeah i have no idea
whether it was in 2016
2017 2018 2019.
i don't
when did you have any conversations with
colleagues at ca
it would have been whenever the
decisions were being made about how to
cast that movie i don't i don't honestly
i don't know what year that was
do you recall who you spoke with
i spoke with
jack wiggum
i spoke with
brian lord
what do you recall jerry bruckheimer
telling you
um
[Music]
i i don't recall the specific
conversations
but
the
nature of it was that the studio
was
having difficulty employing him
and did mr brock crimer
tell you why the studio was having
difficulty employing mr duck
um
no not specifically but it was
understood
did you ask
i didn't need to
why did you think you didn't communicate
because
everyone was aware of
what was garnering the
attention
of the studios and determining whether
or not he could be employed
when you say everyone was aware
how do you know that
i don't know i just knew
can you tell me who everyone
can tell anyone
the the people who would have been
involved in
making that decision
well
if i'm understanding you correctly and
please correct me if i'm wrong
the only person that
disney that you spoke with about pirates
uh and employing mr depp was jerry
blechman correct
um
yes
right and you spoke between five and ten
times
with mr bruckheimer
and he did not say in any of those
conversations
the reason we're not employing mr depp
is because of amber ferd's accusations
of domestic violence and abused by mr
correct
that's good mr carina when we went off
for the break we were talking about your
discussion with jerry bruckheimer and
other executives at caa
respecting
mr depp not being employed further at
disney and likely not pirates
and i think a question came up right
before the break
and so i just want to make sure that i
have clear
did you talk with anyone other than
jerry bruckheimer at disney about mr
depp not being employed again at disney
or pirates
okay
and was i correct that you in a certain
understanding you had somewhere between
five and ten conversations with mr
bruckheimer
to this problem
um probably less than that i talk to
jerry regularly
um
but
probably not that many on this topic
okay and was there anyone else at disney
that you spoke with at any point
about johnny depp being considered for
pirates or not being employable by
disney no
okay and that is that true to the
present
yes okay
uh and the other discussions that you
had
those were all with executives at caa
yes
and that was brian lord and jack william
correct
yes anyone else
not that i can recall now
okay
do you
you had indicated
that you believed that everybody
everyone was aware
um
that the
impact of
amber's
allegations were at the heart of this
uh
if i'm i just want to make sure that
we're clear since we were just talking
about this before the break
jerry bruckheimer did not say
specifically
what it was that caused disney to decide
not to continue with johnny depp and
pirates sex or in other matters correct
correct
well and i'm trying to reach that it was
understood i'm trying to discover any
facts that would have led you to believe
it was understood and if i'm
understanding
you use the same word mr bruckheimer
didn't tell you that correct
again it was understood so
i don't recall whether either of us ever
said anything specific about
why
but
it is something within the industry that
is
understood
can you
tell me whether
any other actors
did not receive roles
or
were unemployable because of the metoo
movement allegations
other than mr gatlin
not that i work with directly now
in any of your discussions with mr
brookhand did you ask him what mr depp
could do
to become employable by disney again or
to be able to get any part of any
pirates
franchise going forward no
why not
because
they're
in cases like this there is nothing
anybody can do it is the
directive of the studio to and they have
the sole right to
make the judgment whether they can
continue to employ somebody or not
and your understanding from your
discussions with mr bruckheimer is that
disney had made
the
judgment to decide that they could no
longer employ mr death is that correct
yes but but not
solely based on conversations with mr
bruckheimer it was cumulative
with the internal and external
conversations
what did
mr
lord say
that led you to believe that
but disney had made the decision the
judgment that they did not were not able
to employ mr death
just just that the decision had been
made
what did mr wiggum say
about
disney making the judgment of whether
they would not be able to employ mr
death perfect same
[Music]
were you aware of any problems
on the step
with mr depp during the filming of
pirates permit are you aware of mr depp
uh engaging on alcohol and drug use
being tardy any of those issues during
the filming of pirate spy
um i'm aware of him being tardy but he's
been tardy on everything in his entire
life
[Music]
were you aware of whether that was
troublesome to
disney during the filming of pirate spy
i think it's troublesome to everybody
but
uh everyone
has learned how to produce a film
dealing to deal with it
working around mr gap
yes
do you know whether there was anyone on
the set of pirates 5 who wasn't willing
to deal with it and was quite irritated
no
were you aware
that
the filming had to be shut down for a
period of time
after mr deb injured his finger
yes
were you aware of any disagreements
between mr depp and disney including mr
bailey and others who were on the
project
about
artistic differences in other words
where mr depp thought something should
be this way or something should be that
way and they didn't agree
yes
okay what is your understanding of that
there was a difference of opinion on
how the film was edited
and what is your understanding of what
mr depp thought it should be
i i don't
know how to describe the difference
between
the disney
edit and johnny's preferred edit
i think
johnny uh
told me about it talked about a little
bit
do you know how well pirates 5 did at
the box items
not exactly
do you know whether it was it was more
successful or less successful than
earlier pirates
i think it was slightly less than i
wasn't the most successful
installment of that franchise
do you know whether mr depp has a payor
play
clause
that would
pay him even if he was not in the
subsequent height of steps
in six
yes
i don't think he does
have
you or any anyone at caa on behalf of mr
deaf
made any efforts
with disney
to
[Music]
find any roles for mr depp
since
he filmed
pirate spy
my
efforts were
probably primarily around houdini which
at one point was a film
but
um other people at ca for sure did yes
[Music]
i would start with jack wiggum
[Music]
um we'll now play volume two of mr
carino's deposition at which
okay maybe time for afternoon sure he's
close enough to it absolutely all right
before we get to volume two let's go
ahead and take a 15-minute break please
do not talk to anybody about the case
and don't do the outside research
all right
okay
okay let's get sure
so
um
all right you want to continue with this
witness then
yes thank you your honor we'll now play
volume two of mr carino's deposition
which is the questioning from council
for mr depp okay thank you
you're aware that this litigation
involves a dispute between uh johnny
depp and amber heard correct
correct
and you know both of those individuals
correct
correct
who did you meet first
amber
when did you meet her
i i don't know
exactly when
but
probably within
the first few years of being at ca
okay
so can we as an estimate stay uh 2005
2006 time frame
sure i don't actually know but sure
but it was pretty early on at your
career at caa
correct
and describe for me the events of your
meeting her
um she was represented theatrically at
the time
by
an agent named warren zavala
who
has since left ca
and he brought her down to my office
because he wanted me to
represent her with him
specifically in the commercial space
and what do you mean represent her in
the commercial space
um help identify business opportunities
for her with brands
okay
so not as an actor
correct
and did you take on that representation
i did
and at some point in time you did
consider her a friend in addition to um
you two working together is that right
yes
and in that regard did
you uh you and her do anything social
yes
and can you describe for me generally
what types of activities you two would
do together as friends
we would uh
go to dinner go to events together
hang out at
each other's
residences
and at some point at some point in time
did you consider mr def a friend
yes
and how did that relationship evolve and
i'm just talking about you and mr death
becoming friends
i
spent
a fair amount of time with
both of them together
and at some point started to spend time
with him on my own as well
and at some point in time did mr depp
become a good a friend to you as miss
heard
i'm sorry
let me re-ask that also
did you consider uh
at some point in time did you consider
mr depp a friend to the same degree you
considered misheard a friend
yes
and at some point let me ask you at some
point in time did you
uh represent
mr depp professionally
yes and can you explain to me how it how
it came to you representing mr debt
professionally
johnny asked me to represent him
and when you began representing mr dev
did you continue representing ms hurd
yes
and do you recall who mr deb's agent was
priority he was represented at another
town agency uta do you still work for mr
death
i do not
you recall when you stopped working for
mr deb
within the past two years
and um can you describe the
circumstances of you no longer working
for mr deb
he
left
caa
to follow
an agent who
left caa
to become part of a founding group in a
new management company
and who is that person
jack wiggum
was mr wiggum ever affiliated with caa
yes
okay and
say that when jack wiggum departed t.a.a
johnny went with him
yes
and
when mr depp left um
left caa
did you remain
did you remain friends with him
no
okay
well i should probably first ask at some
point in time um
did your friendship with mr depan
yes
and when was that
i would say
at the time he left
caa
and did him leaving we have something to
do with the end of the friendship
i don't know are you still friends with
miss heard
no
and when did that friendship end
probably
when
the
legal disputes started
and what legal dispute are you referring
to this one
the
i'm not sure which one was first but one
of the disputes between johnny and amber
okay
your friendship with
you're not referring to their divorce
correct
correct
okay so you remain friends with both of
them through their divorce is that
accurate
yes
although you're no longer friends with
mr depp do you have any animosity
towards him
i do not
and same question with respect to ms
hurd although you're not friends with
her any longer do you have any animosity
towards her i do not
do you recall when it is the last time
you spoke with miss hurd
i do not
would it have been around the same time
that um
your friendship ended with her
i would assume so
exhibit 16
no mr kareem
you'll see at the bottom here and
if you can see it if you see at the
bottom it has a bait stamp number under
the yellow tag cc00070
yes do you recognize this document
and take your time if you need to review
it
yes
yes
okay and do you understand this to be a
true uh an authentic copy of
uh email exchange in which you were
involved
i believe so
okay
okay and it's you'll see it's dated
january 11 2018 and the subject is wme
do you know what what is your
understanding of what wme is
william morris endeavor
what is that
it's another talent agency
okay um
and you've you've read this email from
misheard to you correct
correct
so at this point in time would you
was she a close friend of yours
yes and ultimately did she leave caa
yes
and it was at this time
yes
during the entire time you represented
uh miss misheard
did mr depp ever interfere
with your representation
of misheard
no
did he ever ask you to do anything
uh with respect to
her career
not that i can recall
except at 17
now mr karino this particular document
was not produced by you
you'll see that
at the bottom here
the bait stamp
indicates alh
that means it was produced by miss heard
and
this appears to be a text exchange
between you and her um it's about a page
and a half if you could take the time to
read it and then i will ask you
questions about it
you'll see at the top mr purino that
it's dated
uh july 14 2016.
um based on that date and based on
reading
this
text exchange
at this point in time uh were you close
friends with both mr depp and ms hurd
yes
and having read the text exchange
do you believe do you believe this to be
a
true and correct
representation of the exchange
yes
and to be authentic in that regard
yes
now
uh
you start the text exchange by
indicating jd just surfaced who is what
is the jd reference
johnny depp
and she says i saw laurel yesterday
uh who is laurel
laurel's a therapist
do you know her full name
laurel anderson did you independently
know laurel
yes
did you have anything to do with um
laurel
seeing either
misheard or mr depp yes
can you explain that to me please
i introduced them all
and
was
what was the purpose of you introducing
her to them
they needed
help
and can you explain to me in more detail
what you mean by that
i think it was at a time where they
needed somebody to help mediate
the difficulties they were having
and what do you mean by difficulties
the strains on their relationship and
in that regard
um did you have conversations with miss
heard
about the state of her relationship with
mr death yes i'm trying to determine for
how long a period of time
uh did miss hurt have conversations with
you
about the state of her relationship with
mr death
can you give me um
a time frame
i would say
she talked to me about the state of the
relationship
from the beginning until the end
the entire time you knew her i'm sorry
the entire time you considered her a
friend
yeah
okay
and how about mr dev um would you
how would you
did you have conversations with him
about the state of his relationship with
mr
yes
and were those ongoing during the entire
time you were friends with him yes you
say they both confided in you in that
regard
yes
so back to this text exchange
now where my cursor is um
you i miss her and says to you yeah she
said that johnny and i need to talk
directly do you know who she's do you
know who miss her is referring to there
laura
that was your understanding after
reading this
yes
and then you asked her do you want to do
something tomorrow she says yeah
um
she says idp i do
you say ha
okay
and then you say what is safe to do do
you want to come to my place for dinner
what did you mean by what is safe to do
it meant avoiding paparazzi okay
and then she says
it's so [ __ ] up i just want to tell
him that what they are telling him isn't
true what was your understanding of what
she meant by that sentence
i i don't
recall mr garino while she's doing that
um
at the at the outside of this deposition
i asked you
uh if you recall being deposed about a
year ago in this case
um and you said yes is that accurate
yes
okay what i'm going to show you now is
the transcript portion of the transcript
from that deposition and who is mr
bruckheimer
jerry bruckheimer is the producer of
the pirates franchise and who is mr
wiggum
jack wiggum
was an agent at ca
who worked with johnny
okay
and who is
mr uh lord
brian is one of the managing partners of
caa
and also worked on johnny depp
and what was your understanding of
why
the pirate six
job was not offered to mr deb
leo you're asking my opinion
yes
because of the accusations that amber
had made
and what i'm about to show you mr
carrino is a article in the washington
post
authored by miss heard you're going to
notice that
the article will be presented sideways
so you'll have to tilt your head a bit
to
review it
at 19. do you uh
first mr karina why don't you take
control and just
scroll through uh the document it's just
a couple babies
is this the top of the
next page
yeah when there's a jump like that it's
just at the top of the next page
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
mr crano have you seen this document
before
yes
do you know who wrote this document
yes
who wrote this document amber
amber heard
yes
do you see there on this first page of
the document
it actually indicates that it's written
by amber heard on december 18th 2018.
yes
and you understand that this document
was
authored by miss heard and published on
december 18 2018.
yes
and do you recall reading it at the time
it was published
no
mr uh crano i'm showing you an email
exchange in which you were involved
it's just this one page i'll blow it up
so you can review it
take a second to review it please
okay
and
let's start at the bottom of this well
you see at the top that the email ray
line is entitled johnny depp's jack
sparrow won't return the new pirates of
the caribbean movie
yes
and this email exchange was on december
20th 2018 correct
correct
and do you recall that the article you
just read published by ms heard was
published on december 18 2018 two days
before this
yes
okay
now if you go to the bottom of this
email
do you see there's this link to an
article
yes
and it says uh
url defense
oh i'm sorry it says movieweb.com
yes
mr carino what i put up next to the
email exchange that we've been
discussing
is an article
dated december 20th 2018 okay
so this article is dated december 20th
2018.
the email sent to you by
robin baum
is that same day december 20th 2018
correct
yes
who is miss bomb
johnny's publicist
and she's sending this article to you is
that right
yes
and then in response you say
um we were were we told
this officially from disney
and she responds uh
i'm sorry jack wiggum responds no is
that accurate
yes
sure
so you testified just
a few minutes ago that it was your
opinion that mr depp
lost
the pirate six movie because of
misheard's allegations is that accurate
allegations of abuse correct
yes
and
is this a demonstration of
when
disney made that decision to not
uh hire mr deb for pirate sticks
yes
exhibit 22.
did you ever see
mr death
more physically abused misheard
no
did miss herd ever tell you that she had
been physically abused by mr death
no did you did mr depp ever tell you
that he had physically abused miss hurt
no
did you ever witness
um any
injuries on misheard that would indicate
that she was physically abused
no
now again this is a few months after the
filing of the divorce papers
and the tro
and miss heard states to you i'll call
you right back sorry
and you say okay
she says is it too late to call
and you say just finishing dinner we'll
call you as soon as we walk out within
20.
and she says please tell him
i love
him um
is that an accurate reading of the text
exchange so far
yes
do you know if at this time
based on your relationship with miss
hurt and mr depp
um
whether
miss heard wanted to reconcile with mr
deb
yes
did you understand that she did
yes
did
miss heard
based on your personal friendship with
miss her close personal friendship with
miss heard
would you say
that she confided in you
and what about mr yes
mr craig at some point in time
after ms heard
filed his divorce papers in may of 2016
did she
make any requests of you to
intervene in
the relationship between her and mr bill
what do you mean by intervene
assist in let's start with assisting
communications between the two
same
objections can you explain to me what
transpired in that regard
walk me through
at some point around that time
she wanted
me to arrange for them to get together
in person
and
what did you do
after that was requested of you by mr
i
talk to johnny about it what happened
after that
uh he was reluctant
at first and then agreed
and then what happened after that
i mean is a long time ago but
i remember
there was a fair amount of discussion
about
the tro
and how we would deal with that because
nobody
wanted johnny accused of violating the
tro
as an outcome of
that meeting
and i don't remember exactly what we
did
but
amber at some point warranted that she
would never accuse him of violating the
tro to do the meeting
and
i set the meeting up
so just so i understand
you set the meeting up
at the request of mr
objection
um
you know as part of you setting up
she told you that
it didn't matter
what i'm trying to understand what what
was the issue with respect to the tro
my understanding of a
restraining order at least at the time
was that
he couldn't go within a certain
distance of
her
okay
and what was her suggestion
um
with respect to that issue
in connection with her wanting to meet
with him
she
promised me and told me to relay to him
that she would never accuse him
of violating
the restraining order
as a result of agreeing to meet her
and i believe but i don't
recall exactly there were conversations
with
both
sides legally i believe at the time
to make it transparent to everybody that
this was happening
okay
and then what happened next
um i arranged the meeting johnny was
in
san francisco
um
on tour
and i arranged to borrow a friend's
house
and
amber and i flew to
[Music]
san francisco and drove to the house
and
johnny showed up a few hours later
and did the two of them meet
yes
in the same room
they sat outside
okay
uh
how close to each other were they
inches away from each other
and how long uh
were they out there talking for how long
were they out there talking
several hours
did you although you were out there did
you
were you in a position where you could
see them through a window or otherwise
yes
at some point in time the conversation
ended correct
correct and what happened after that
i
received a call or a text from
steve whose house it was
and he
notified me that
he would be coming back
to the house
within the next hour or so
and
i told
johnny and amber
and we decided to rent a hotel room in
san francisco
so that they could continue to talk
and did that in fact happen
and at some point in time you left that
house correct to go to san francisco
yes
and was it the three of you
no
johnny had security with him
and
we talked about the fact that they
it wouldn't be
a good idea for them to be seen together
there
so
johnny left with his security in his car
and i believe
amber and i took an uber
and what happened after that
we all met at the hotel
room
and you know what happened after that
um they started arguing
and do you recall any details of the
argument
no and for how long were you was this
argument had in a in a hotel room
yes
did you witness the entire discussion or
did you leave at some point
i left the next morning at
five
o'clock in the morning or six o'clock in
the morning
and mr carino um i'm showing you emails
over produced by you first uh the bottom
of the first page it starts at the
bottom the first page the string above
it was redacted and you'll see that it
starts on august 7th 2017. do you see
that
august 7th 2017. yes having read it
can you determine who you're speaking
with in this text exchange amber oh hang
on let me ask you this
do you know whether or not um
miss heard ever
had a relationship with mr elon musk
yes
she did
yes again it's dated
august
of 2017
um
and she says dealing with breakup
i hate when things go public
see i'm so sad
having reviewed the document again do
you have an understanding of what she's
referencing there
um i believe she's referring to breaking
up with elon
you say it seems like a press release
you weren't in love with him and you
told me a thousand times you were just
filling space
what are you saying there
i'm saying
why would you be sad if you weren't in
love with them to begin with
and by him you're referring to who
elon
and at this point in time
were you still close friends with miss
heard
uh looks looks like that's the case at
that time yes
and was did she still at this point in
time did she confide in you about her
relationships
yes okay
and you respond
i'm sorry she responds
i know but i wanted time to grieve and
recover
in my own time
is she still referring to mr musk there
do you know
your understanding i don't know whether
she's referring to johnny or to elon in
that line
okay
in this point of time do you know uh
what her feelings were what was your
understand at this point in time what
was your understanding based on
your experience with her
what was your understanding
of her relationship with mr deb
i
i don't believe
there was a relationship at that point
and
you say and you got that no she says
i hate that
yet again a man lets me fall on the
spikes by myself
you ask how so
she says
oops
meaning
they are mad at me for leaving them and
put things like this out there
you say
like
sorry
she says like that
you say
you could avoid all this if you stop
dating uber famous people you can be
with a big man who isn't famous
what were you
relating to her there
i believe what i was saying was
if you don't like being in the press
about your personal life then
don't date people that are famous sure
um you indicated that she moved on
immediately
after jd
after i'm sorry after johnny depp to
date elon musk is that accurate
yes okay sure
do you have an understanding one way or
another whether miss hurd and mr musk
were in fact dating at the time of the
san francisco
reconciliation that she asked you to set
up i i don't know whether they were
dating
but they
had definitely spent time together
[Music]
do you
do you know how long after the san
francisco attempted reconciliation you
gained the understanding that elon musk
and mr were in fact dating
i don't know
exactly how long but not long after
do you know who she's
what was your understanding of who she
was referring to when she was said here
i love him
johnny
based on this exchange did you have an
understanding at this time
whether miss
heard wanted to reconcile with mr duff
i believe
she did
and at this point in time she was still
a close personal friend of yours correct
yes
and uh at this point in time was she uh
did she consider you a confidant in your
understanding
i i think
yeah
okay just to uh
authenticate this document again mister
do you see that
it's referenced at the bottom bait stamp
cc indicating that you produced this
document yes
and um
af having read this do you do you
perceive this as a traumatic copy of the
text exchange between you and mr ms
heard
yes
okay
and i will
um can you see at the very top here it's
dated august 16th 2017.
and miss heard states to you
i've written so many notes
can you give him one
i don't know how or where to start
there's no way to begin and
all i have to say but i have so many
finally i am single clear in my heart
and mind i just want him to know i loved
loved him and that i am sorry
do you have an understanding of who miss
hurt is referring to here yes
and who is misheard referring to in this
text johnny
and what is she um
asking you to do here
she was asking me to
deliver
a letter
that she was writing to him
and
did she also want you to and it says and
that i am sorry
uh what was your understanding what she
was asking you to do there if anything
i believe that was all in reference to
getting him
a handwritten letter that she was
writing or trying to write was it your
understanding at the time of this text
exchange august 24 2017 that miss amber
was attempting to reconcile with mr deb
and i know this may sound repetitive but
on august 20 at the time of this text on
august 24 2017
um you and her were still close personal
friends correct
i believe so
there's not much here at all about
mr carino but i didn't want to confirm
that this was a document produced by you
correct based on the bait stamp on the
bottom
yes
and
do you see it's dated september 27 2017
september 23rd
oh you're right my apologies
it's dated september 23 2017 and it's a
text to you that says god i miss him
do you have an understanding of
what
not
who ms heard is referring to there
yes
and who's that
johnny
and
do you see
at the bottom
the date of the text is june 9th 2018.
yes
okay
and
it says i text him happy birthday
do you know who sent that and who the
humans i assume this is from amber and
she's talking about johnny you've had a
chance to review the whole document um
what is
what is it what does this appear to be
uh it appears to be the communications
around the time that we
set up the meeting
in um
and who are these communications between
me and johnny
okay
and this first
bubble
can you tell if that if the blue is you
or mr depp
ah i think the blue is is me
sure earlier in your deposition
at the very outset i was asking you
about
your representation of individuals
at caa
you indicated that you represent
individuals that are both actors and
musicians
would you consider mr depp in that pool
yes
and you represented your ca represented
both in connection with his acting
endeavors
and
his involvement with
the vampires
yes
and
was mr deb's participation in hollywood
vampires lucrative
no
uh do you know whether or not it was
something mr jeff mr depp enjoyed
yes
plaintiff calls laura wasser by
deposition your honor w a
s
s
e
r
will you please state your name and
address for the record
laura allison wasser
wasser cooperman and mandels suite 820
2049 century park east los angeles
california at 90049.
thank you what is your occupation
i'm an attorney at law
and how long have you been an attorney
26 years
you represented mr depp in the divorce
against amber heard is that correct
yes
and you are here under subpoena
yes
your practice has primarily been focused
on domestic relations in california is
that correct
yes
are you a member of any bar other than
california
no
during the period 2012 to 2016
was california a no-fault state with
respect for divorce the answer is that
california was a no-fault state during
that period
during the period 2012 to 2016 was
california a community property slope
with respect to the division of assets
in the divorce
yes
and what does that mean to you
california as a community property state
and what that means to me is that assets
which were earned or created during the
course of the marriage
absent some other
theory of law applied be divided equally
and
what do you mean by absolutely some
theory
or law applied
i'm sorry elaine what was the question
oh a theory of a lot when i say a theory
of lie mean if there's a premarital
agreement if there's some other
um it's not completely uh blanket
community property there may be
things that were earned from a separate
property source that would not be
considered
community property so i was just trying
to
provide
for the record
some exceptions to what would be
considered community property and
therefore divided equally
now if someone alleges domestic violence
or abuse against their spouse would that
change the amount they would otherwise
be entitled to under community property
laws
no
in obtaining
a temporary restraining order
what is your understanding of the
process
the moving party files
generally with uh 24 hours notice
to the person who is being accused of
domestic violence
a declaration and forms
with the court
and
requests a temporary
domestic violence restraining order
that will generally last no longer than
a 21 day period
when the defendant is able to make his
or her
arguments as to why such a restraining
order would be inappropriate
and
the temporary restraining order can it
be continued
yes
when did you first begin representing mr
depp relating to his divorce within
behave
um
i believe it was in
december of 2015.
i'm going to
ask you to pull up
document one washer document one and
let's go ahead and label that as washer
exhibit number one
ms watson i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as wasser
deposition exhibit number one
it is a letter dated may 24 2016.
it's addressed to jacob
uh and it says re in remarriage of death
do you see that
yes
okay and it's from
samantha spector
who indicates she's representing amber
heard
as of the time of this letter
had you made known to
amber heard or miss spectre
or anyone else related to them that you
represented mr depp
i don't believe so
did you
receive a copy of this letter from
someone
i believe so i think i've seen it before
so yes
did you receive this letter
on or around may 24 2016.
okay next page please
hang on
yes it was around that time
around may 24 2016
yes
did you have any communications with
samantha specter
in connection with this letter
yes
and when you say within days
could it have been the same day may 24th
the next day 25th
possibly i'm going to direct your
attention to the next paragraph it says
to this end please have johnny promptly
sign and return by friday may 27 2016.
the enclosed notice of acknowledgement
received from
confirming service of the summons
petition law case cover sheet and blank
response did you do that
this letter was not directed to me
elaine
no i i understand it but it was given to
you correct
i believe so
and you were representing mr deb correct
yes
and
mr bloom did not represent mr depp in
connection with the
divorce correct
correct
so
once
mr bloom gave this to you
then
did you represent mr depp going forward
in communications with cement
perspective
once we received this letter
our firm took over with representation
of mr depp in the dissolution action
i cannot recall
whether or not
the
request made was done by
friday may 27th but i believe that it
was
probably that notice and acknowledgement
of receipt somewhere with a date on it
now the next section i think is
something that you referred to earlier
said in addition we are requesting on
amber's behalf the following and it
talks about it says appropriate
condensate like support
uh
did you have an understanding of what
that amount might be at the time that
you saw this letter
i did not have an understanding of what
appropriate pendente lite support would
be at that time did you ask spectre
i don't recall
i don't recall our specific
communications regarding her requests
do you recall
making any kind of counter to any of
these items
all i recall is that
without any notice to us at 8 30 in the
morning on the 27th
samantha spector and her client went
into court and obtained a no notice
ex parte
restraining order
had you had any communications
with samantha specter prior to her going
into court
on that friday may 27th
yes
how many communications have you had
with ms spector prior
following getting this letter and prior
to her going into court at 8 30 on may
27 2016.
i do not recall
do you have a recollection of whether
any of the communications that you had
with ms spector between the receipt of
this letter
that's dated may 24 2016 and going and
miss specter going into court on
friday may 27 2016
related in any way to requests on your
behalf on behalf of your client
that you made
now
you recall having communications with
samantha specter
between may 24 and may 27
you can't recall how many and you can't
recall
the specifics of those communications is
that accurate
it's not accurate
and
in what way please tell me
i recall that we had communications
between the 24th and probably the 26th i
doubt we spoke on the morning of the
27th before she went into court i do not
know the content of those communications
and i do not know how many
communications were had
now on the
next paragraph it has a proposal for
private
retired judicial officers
ultimately did you and ms spector talk
about using private retired judicial
officers whether it was the list she
provided or any others
i believe so yes
and what do you recall
my recollection is that is in almost all
of our cases certainly those with high
profile
clients
we would have liked to take it out of
the system
ms spector was not willing to do that
with this case
what do you recall this specter saying
to indicate that she did not want to
take it out of the contract
i don't recall her saying anything
[Music]
now
after your understanding was that a
class dv tro was in fact obtained on
friday may 27 2016 by ms heard against
mr jeff correct
that is my understanding
after that
did there come a time
that you or anyone on on
at your law firm communicated with the
eastern columbia building concierge
staff or management
were those the downtown lofts
the the penthouse lofts yes
it's and if it's easier for you
everyone's been referring to the eastern
columbia building as ecb
would that be helpful at all
sure or we can if you prefer to call
them the penthouse loft building that's
fine too
now that we've identified them i
understand what you're talking about we
can call them whatever you'd like
did someone from my firm speak with
somebody uh at the
at those
buildings yes
and
who from your firm spoke with someone at
the buildings
and when
[Music]
i believe either i did or my partner
samantha klein or
an associate who is also working on the
case
lisa sutton
from our firm
we also had co-counsel on the case they
may have been involved
as to when
i have to imagine it was sometime
in
june or july
of
2016.
now you you indicated either you or
samantha klein or lisa sutton and you
also had co-counsel do you have a
specific recollection of speaking with
anyone at the ecb
building
i don't
what were samantha klein's
communications with the ecb building
i don't know
were
what were samantha klein's communication
with easy with the ecb building
okay and her answer was i don't know
what were what were lisa's sentence
communications with the ecb building
i don't know
what were
your co-consul's communications with the
ecb building when i say ecd building i'm
not talking about the structure i'm
talking about the individuals who worked
there
and just so we're clear here you don't
recall any communications with the ecb
building staff as well correct you asked
me if i had a specific recollection i do
not
do you have a general recommendation
i believe that at some point we
subpoenaed the building's records of
the
video
from the lobby and elevator areas
so i would imagine that the
communications would have to do with
those subpoenas
are you able
to testify to any
conversation
you
or anyone at your firm or your co-consul
had with the ecb building staff
i am sure that there were conversations
and communications regarding
the production of
the subpoenaed documents
review of the subpoena documents
their compliance with i believe it was
ms spector's
subpoena
that was sent
our ability to review the video's
coordination of same but i don't have a
specific recollection
of any communications
are you able to speak to whether there
were any conversations
between you
anyone at your law firm or your
co-consul and ecb building personnel
prior to your issuing the subpoena
also i don't believe that the subpoena
was issued by our firm
so you don't have a recollection
of a subpoena being issued
on mr depp's behalf
for the
ecb building
surveillance tapes
i don't know i know there was one issued
i believe it was issued by miss specter
let's talk about the videos that you
just referred to from the ecd buildings
app
how did you and your firm or your
co-counsel
receive these videos
i don't recall i would imagine a like a
e-file or something like that
now is it your recollection
that there was just one e-file that
contained all of the surveillance tapes
i don't have a recollection as to
whether it was one or seven or what i
just don't know
when you were talking about receiving
the video surveillance footage
on whatever whether it was one file or
seven files whether it was e-file or
whatever did you have any understanding
that you were not provided the full
amount that was requested whatever the
amount was
no
so you thought you
received whatever you were supposed to
receive is that clear
yes
what did you do
with the actual
surveillance video footage that you
received
i believe we kept it on the computer at
least for the next couple of months in
preparation for trial
i don't know where it is now that's my
next question
is there a time
that you
no longer possess the video surveillance
footage that was sent to you
by the ecb building
i don't know
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
what has been marked as watson
deposition exhibit number two and it's a
multi-page document
and so i'm going to
scroll down a little bit but
you let me know if i'm going too fast
here um
it's dated june 3rd
and it's to samantha klein she's with
your she was working with you on the
depth case correct
correct
okay and it's from samantha specter
which you can see there and we'll show
you the signature later
and it's litigation called preservation
of information
not limited to electronically stored
information you see that yes
do you recall receiving this letter and
if you want me to scroll down and let
you read each page i'm happy to do that
first i'm familiar with this letter i
recall receiving it
and
did you receive this letter
before
you received the
surveillance
footage from the ecb building
um
i am not sure
well i think you had indicated that you
thought that it was in june or july that
you received the surveillance is that
still your best recollection
i'm
looking at the date and knowing the
chronology of the case it is
my best estimate that we received this
letter prior to the time that we
received
the video footage
ms wasser
what steps did you and your firm and
co-consul take
to preserve the surveillance
video footage of easton b
from the time you received it going
forward
i think
the absence of us doing anything to
destroy the video footage would be the
most i could testify regarding in terms
of steps that we took to preserve
the video footage
are you aware
of any destruction of the video footage
the surveillance video footage from ecb
up to the present
no i we probably still have it have have
you looked for it
no
have you been asked to look for it
no
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
what has now been march's washington
exhibit number three
and it's dated june 6 2013
addressed to you
and it's from charles carter did you
have an understanding that mr carter
also represented angerford
i did when i received this letter on
june 6.
and did you have an understanding that
mr carter was also asking you to
preserve
any evidence
yes
okay
ms wasser i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as lawson
deposition exhibit number four it's
dated june 6 as well and it's the
charles carter from your phone
and you are acknowledging we see that
the preservation demand matter from this
heard as well as his
uh and you indicated
we are fully aware of our obligations
with respect to the preservation of
evidence
please rest assured that we intend to
comply with the preservation demand and
expect that ms burden will do so as well
do you recall saying that in this letter
yes
and was this letter in fact from you to
mr harder
it was
miss so i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as roster
deposition exhibit number five it's a
letter dated june 21 2016
to samantha spector charles carter and
leonard levine i think it's pronounced
remarriage of death
and it's from
this
and you are copied on it do you see that
i do okay and miss klein worked with
your law firm
yes
and represented mr deputy as well
is that correct yes okay
i'm going to go back up to the beginning
to call your attention to a particular
section
it says this letter shall confirm the
agreements we reached yesterday with
respect to the pending domestic violence
proceeding you see that
and then we're going to go down to the
media
press and it says neither party nor his
or her respective council
representatives or agents so make any
comments in the media or press
pertaining to this dissolution action
the civil action opinion against judges
for note and are any pending or future
litigation between our
and or involving the parties do you see
that
yes all right does that
uh
accurately reflect the agreement that
was made between
the parties with respect to the
neighborhood and mr depp in
communications with the press
yes
do you know liz walton's
who
liz walters
yes
and who is she
she is a reporter
or
i believe she works for her brother's
online media outlet called the blast
did you have any communications with liz
walters during the depth her divorce i
don't recall
[Music]
did you have any communication with your
tmz relating to the depth or divorce i
don't recall
now
the
what do you recall what the date was for
the permanent
uh tro temporary restraining order
do you recall the date that you said
that early on 21 days after the
temporary restraining order is typically
the date that's set for the hearing for
the defendant if they want to come in
and oppose it or if the
petitioner wants to extend it you recall
what the first date was
i don't but i would imagine it was
probably at some point in early june
all right and then do you recall that
date being continued
i do
how many times at least twice possibly
three times i think that the final
date was at some point in august and we
settled
right before then
all right jim
can we bring up
number
document number seven
thank you
mr i'm going to ask you to take a look
at what has been marked as wasser
exhibit number seven
it is dated august 5 2016.
it is to you
from
samantha specter do you see that
yes do you recall did you receive this
document
but doesn't it say at the top that it's
protected under 1152
it sure does all i'm asking you is
whether you received it i'm not not
asking you about the substance
i don't remember
do you have any reason to believe you
did not receive it
i don't
laster i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as roster
deposition exhibit number eight uh and
it starts out
with a name now from samantha specter to
amber on august 6 2016.
um
do you recall
what was going on on or around august 16
it's
divorced
in connection with the divorce
not specifically no
do you know who christian carino is
i do
okay who is he
he's an agent a creative artist agency
how long have you known christian colino
i've known of christian for maybe
10 years
were you aware that mr carrino was
involved
in
organizing if you will or assisting mr
devin is hard
with
their own
meeting to try to resolve
their case up in san francisco
possibly that sounds vaguely familiar
you on the telephone
at any point while amber hurd and john
depp were meeting
to discuss
attempted resolution at the resolution
of the issues during the summer of 2016.
what was your question was i on the
telephone
yes
were you on the telephone
where mr depp and ms heard
were in the hotel room
and were talking
no
were you ever on the telephone
when ms hurd and mr depp were together
talking during the summer of 2016. no
matter where they were
on the telephone yes
no
while he was with ms heard and miss
heard was on speaker that and you were
on speakerphone with two of them
no
you recognize the name
do you recognize the name on what
joe sweeney
i do
and who was he
joe sweeney is a forensic accountant
who specializes in family law forensic
accounting and he was ms heard's
forensic accountant in the disso matter
and was edward white
acting as the forensic accountant for mr
death
no
did mr white provide the documentation
that was then submitted to samantha
specter as counsel from his heart
i believe
came from mr white's office also
probably of note is the fact that uh mr
depp
changed business management
shortly before or during the course of
the case so it is possible that some of
the documents came from predecessor
business manager
i'm going to show you what
has been marked as washer deposition
exhibit number 10
and i'm not going to ask you
any specific questions so i don't need
you to have to review it in detail
unless you'd like to you're certainly
welcome to spend as much time as you'd
like on it but i'm just going to go down
to the end of it
and i'm going to
ask if this
is the deal point memorandum that you
referred to that was finalized on august
2016.
since the party's signatures appear at
the bottom as well as ms spector's in
mine i believe that this is the deal
point memorandum that to which i was
referring okay
is there any reason to believe
that it is not
the the final deal point memorandum
no
ms wasser i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as washer
deposition exhibit number 11
and it's a series of
documents an fl 150 for example
and then
that's page four four and then it goes
into
the next
part one of one
just trying to page through it for you
just so you can see generally
do you recognize this document
yes
could you tell me what it is please
it looks to be
one of the parties i guess mr depp's uh
what we call in california preliminary
or perhaps final declaration of
disclosure there's financial disclosure
forms
ms lassen i'm going to ask you
if you can
take a look at what has been marked as
blaster exhibit number 12
and it's a
many pages
i think it's 50 total
do you recognize this document
yes
can you tell me what it is
it's the party's
related judgment for dissolution of
marriage
is there a specific amount
that was paid to amber heard as part of
this divorce settlement and judgment
for suggestion talking i'm sorry
for her claims of domestic violence
including any claims of assault battery
intentional or inflation of emotional
distress viable slender indoor
definition
i don't believe that we segregated out
what the total amount was being paid for
did you make any effort to seal sbal
the records
in this case and i'm referring to the
case in front of us the uh
the the
marriage or partnership with amber laura
depp and john christopher depp ii
filed in superior court of california
county los angeles
when you say sealed do you mean by the
court to ask the court to seal the file
yes
i don't believe so
why not
we don't do that i'm going to ask you to
take a look at what has been marked as
deposition exhibit number 13
and this is a subpoena
of you for this deposition did you
receive that
do you want you want me to scroll
through it would you like to
no i i i believe that we received it all
right and and you are testifying
pursuant to this subpoena correct
i am
i'm going to ask you to look at what has
been marked as deposition exhibit number
14
um and this is
for the corporate designee of washer
cooperman and
mendoz you see that
for
today's deposition
is it your understanding that you are
the corporate designee on behalf of
wasser cooperman and mendel's
speaking today
yes
thank you
all right ladies and gentlemen i think
uh giving the hour that'll be all the
testimony that you hear today okay so
we'll go ahead and recess for the day
make sure you don't do any outside
research and don't talk to anybody we'll
see you tomorrow okay get some good rest
all right thank you
okay
and tomorrow then we'll be starting with
that other deposition
that's correct and how long is that or
approximately
two and a half hours i'll take care of
the morning probably for the most part
and then you have remote witnesses after
that is that correct
okay so you can get me the contact
information for those so we can get that
taken care of all right just remember we
do plan accordingly because i do need to
take lunch between 1 30 and 2 30 because
there's a graduation i have to speak at
so we're going to take care of that okay
all right thank you have a good evening
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
here
wow
[Music]
ah
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
okay
[Music]
uh
oh
[Applause]
with
so
foreign